- Here's some sipping ASMR.
(Garnt sips)
- Well, I'm hard.
(Joey chuckling)
- Just another Tuesday.
(bright music)
When we're recording this,
the Mori episode is out
which was weird to just mention, right?
- Yeah, I love-
- Just like breaking NDA.
- I love how they legitimately
figured it out like day one.
- I'm not surprised you
made it really obvious.
- Like, on the day.
They were like, "You should, could it be?"
- No, it wasn't that, it was the threat
that was like "Here's the evidence,
of like the past few weeks
that I've collected."
- We haven't tried to hide
it, like we made it obvious.
- I think I saw three videos,
of people-
- You saw three videos?
- Yeah, I saw three videos
of people being like,
"Here's what's up in Hollow Live News.
The Trash Taste Boys tweeted out a tweet.
That is exactly the same as Mori Calli..."
He sounded exactly like that too.
'Cause, you know, they
all sound like that.
- Well, welcome to this
episode of Trash Taste,
I'm your host CDawg Monkey Brain.
- You really clearly
slayed your way in there.
- Yeah, and I'm here
today with Joey and Garnt
and I'm tired as fuck.
- We're just back,
we've just the boys now.
(chuckling)
- Why are you so tired Connor?
- I was up all night and then
I didn't sleep very well.
And I was considering
canceling my Japanese lesson
because I can cancel it online.
But if I do it, like after
6:00 PM the day before
I don't get my money back.
- Oh really?
- So its like-
- Wait, do you pay every lesson?
It's not like a monthly thing?
- You pay for like tokens, and then-
- What?
- Like the token you can like redeem-
- What, is this like the gacha currency?
(both chuckling)
- No, its like-
- That's what I was thinking, right?
- Not everything is fucking
gacha with you guys,
(chuckling) like-
- So, how do you earn tokens?
Could you earn tokens by
just going to the store?
- Pay to win currency
guys, called the money.
Don't know if you've heard of it?
- Can you claim them
like in game as well or?
- Oh my God, you guys have
been playing gacha too much.
- Like, do you have
like dailies for like...
Every lesson you go to
there is like dailies,
you got like five tokens a day?
- I'm just gonna ignore that.
- Then finally, I can do my 10 pool.
- You can explain now Connor.
- Okay, finally are the jokes done?
- [Garnt] Yeah
(chuckling)
- You just pay
and then you get like X
amount of lessons with it.
But like private lessons cost more
like class lessons, cost X.
I mean, I'm sure people can figure
out which school I'm going to now.
- [Joey] Right.
(both chuckles)
- I mean, someone already fucking did.
Someone like approached me and was like-
- [Joey] Really.
- Yeah, they were like, I
was talking with my teacher,
it was like a common area
and 'cause you got like a 10 minute break
and we were talking and
then some guy was like,
"Hey, are you like the guy on YouTube?"
And I'm like,
(Joey chuckling)
"Which guy?"
(all laughing)
- The guy.
- Like, I guess I am, like, yeah.
- You know, the white British guy.
- Yeah, I probably already told the story
on the podcast there, but yeah.
I mean, so yeah, that's
it, and I'm tired as fuck
'cause I went to it and I was like,
"I probably should've
canceled and just slept in."
But again-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, that's-
- You knew fully well, we're gonna do
a podcast episode today?
- I did, but I've been
doing it every week,
but for a lesson before.
- I'm like impressed that
we've been able to manage
like this weekly schedule
without taking a single week off
since we started, I think, right?
- I think so, I mean we've maybe one off,
but other than that we've
been pretty consistent.
- We've had one off simply
because one of the cameras broke
for this one week.
- That's right, one of
the cameras did break.
- Yeah.
- But to compensate, we
did two episodes one week.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, 'cause I'm sure it's
obvious to the viewers at home
but this set up, is all
been set up by like,
I guess us, mainly me, but-
(Garnt chuckling)
- Mainly you, yeah.
We just chilling.
- So, when like the camera died
and I didn't know what
I was doing, I was like,
"Oh, fuck, okay.
I guess we're not filming today."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- To know one of the cameras was broken
we had to get it fixed which-
- For no reason at all, we
never figured that out, yeah.
- Have you guys been up to
anything exciting recently?
- Well, I've got some news.
- Oh.
- oh, shit, okay.
- Yeah, I've got some news.
I just wanna say that this might be
the last podcast episode that I do.
- [Both ] What?
- Because if you guys saw on Twitter,
I've recently been emailed by-
(Garnt and Connor chuckling)
By, you know, you might know them,
they are called Big Hit Labels.
(Garnt laughing)
They are the management of a BTS.
- Oh, yeah I know, I actually
auditioned myself remember?
Like-
- Yeah, I remember.
- Someone signed me up as well.
- But, they emailed me
and it was all Caps.
The title of the email was
all Caps, IDLE CASTING.
(both chuckling)
And so I was like, Oh, shit
and then I saw, Big Hit
and I'll read the email to you right now.
- Go on.
- 'Cause the first time
I saw this, I was like,
Oh my God, is this actually Big Hit?
'Cause that'd be crazy."
But then, because, it...
And like, I'll read it
but like the first half
sounds legitimate.
It says like, "Hello The Anime Man,
we are Big Hit Labels, BTS's
management from South Korea.
We are very interested in
casting you to be a member
of the new boy group in the
Japanese branch of our company."
And this was the moment,
the next word I read,
I realized, oh, this is all a lie.
"Japanese branch of our company, STD!"
(all laughing)
- Okay.
- "We think you'd make a fine-
- That's kinda catchy.
- Yeah, STD.
"We think you'd make a fine visual
with your astonishing idol-looks
or maybe a good leader
with your wisdom and old age."
What the fuck does that mean?
(all laughing)
- Old age?
- Old age.
"If you have anyone else in mind
who you think would fit,
please let us know."
And they gave me a list of requirements
that I needed, all right?
- Okay.
- To be the leader of STD.
- [Connor] What was it?
- Okay, "must speak Japanese."
- All right, check.
- Got that covered.
- Okay.
- "Must be six feet or over." Check.
- "Must be hot, "not sure about that.
Must be hot."
- Well (chuckling)
- He's a lovely oxymoron,
"Must be somewhat feminine, must be male."
(both chuckling)
- Well, yeah, you can rock it.
- "Must look good in tight leather pants."
- Hell yeah, hell yeah.
- And then this last one fucking kill me.
"Singing and dancing would also be good."
(both laughing)
- Would be good.
- Would be good, "Kindly
consider our offer
and get back to us when
possible, Big Hit Label."
- Okay, but what if it was a legit Big Hit
and they reached out to
you, what would you do?
- No, because like-
- What if it was them?
- No, what if it was?
- Like, what if it was-
- Hypothetically.
- Yeah, Big Hit is like, "Joey,
we want you in the band."
What would you say?
- Dude, I would 100% say yes.
Are you kidding me?
Do you know how much of fun...
I could-
- Think of the content.
- Dude, think of the content.
- Think of the stories we can
tell on Trash Tastes, Connor.
- Yeah, I became a K-pop
idol for X amount of time.
(Garnt chuckling)
- How confident are you in the
singing and dancing aspect?
- In dancing, I'm basically
a middle-aged white man
so, I can't dance to save my life.
I think I'm okay at singing (chuckling)
but yeah, dude, now could you imagine STD?
- I would like radiate the same energy
as going to your
accountant and being like,
"Yeah, do that like
tax fraud thing for me.
(both chuckling)
Save me all the money,
do what Trump did, dude."
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- Yeah, pretty cool-
- "Fix me up like that."
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
You know someone actually like
submitted like an audition
with my business email, like legit to them
and they replied being like-
- [Joey] No.
- I think it was no or
like to do the next step
or something, like it was
some like verification thing
and I was like, oh, thanks.
But I've had so many, I've had like
every single dating site you can imagine.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like I've had like SingleMuslim.com,
be signed up for christianmingle.com.
- Classy, did you get Farmers Only?
- No, I haven't had that,
was there a website?
- Yeah, Farmers Only is
like only you have to own
like a certain amount
of land to be eligible.
So like-
- Seriously?
- Yeah.
- You have to own like
certain amounts of acres?
- You have to own a certain
amount of acres of farm land
to be eligible for it.
- I'm like, I see these and I
don't think anything about it
but I remember that I have like an agency
looking at our emails and that's
when I started to get like
kind of worried about it.
And Mayline the other day, he goes to me.
"Oh, there was a weird
email in your email.
That apparently you had matched positive
for STDs with someone.
(both laughing)
Like someone you had slept with had STDs."
And I'm like, Mayline,
it's obviously fake.
One, if I thought I had an STD,
I would go to the fucking
doctor not a website, right?
- Let's just use my work email,
which I know my agency checks to be like,
by the way let's get
an STD check right now.
- It's like how many
terrible decisions in a row
would I have to make to have that?
Like, I would one, have
to sleep with someone
who I would have to be like,
wow, you knows, no condom.
Then go in, think I have
an STD immediately after,
not go to the doctor,
sign up to this website,
hm, final step use work email.
(all laughing)
Like do you ever meet people who are like,
"Man, I just can't seem to get a W."
And then they just don't think.
But they always should do
things that never set it up.
- Yeah.
- That's the kind of
behavior that they do,
that they're just like, "Man,
I'm just so unlucky in life."
And it's like, you did
drive with no wheels.
Like what did you expect to
happen, like this is all you.
- [Joey] I think we all
know like one person
that is like that.
- He's like the nicest person ever
but they keep doing dumb stuff
and you're like, "Come on, man."
- I'm like, you have to be like...
No one person can take that many ELLs
without actually trying to do so, right?
(Joey chuckling)
- I've got like three
friends, you just like,
"Come on, man, I wanna see you get a W,
you just keep doing it, man, stop man."
- Dude, like that BTS one though,
the Big Hit Labels one, like I posted it
'cause I thought it was hilarious, right?
And it is, but you know I
quickly learned my lesson
to not fuck with K-pop fan.
- You felt the wrath of K-pop Twitter?
- Yeah.
- Which-
- Just the Twitter rule.
- I woke up in the morning
and I saw that the thing
had 800 quote retweets.
And I was like-
- Oh no.
- "That's never a good sign."
- Oh, no, (chuckling) boy's
about to get rationed.
- And I checked it and like
a lot of them are just,
you know people just saying,
obviously getting that
it's a joke but you know,
there's those handful of K-pop stands
who would just like,
"Wow, how dare you like
stereotype all K-pop stars?"
- I don't worry about
it, its what they do-
- Oh, no I thought it
was fucking hilarious,
but there are some people who are like,
"Oh, he probably photo-shopped it
just to get attention." I'm like,
What? I'm not that desperate
for likes on Twitter.
- [Connor] That's got like more creativity
than half my videos-
- Yeah.
- That's also the Photoshop-
- The only reason I posted
it because I thought
it was fucking hilarious,
like I wouldn't have
(chuckling) otherwise.
- It's weird that people assume that like
that's the kind of
content we think we need.
- [Both] Yeah.
- That's like, that's the amount
of steps that would jump in through-
- Yeah, that's how desperate
I am for Twitter clout.
Yeah, that I have to fake an email.
- The amount of loops you
would have to jump through
to get to that point,
you know what I mean?
- Oh my God.
- You could just say, I like hentai
and you get more likes.
(chuckling)
- So true.
- Dude, I tweeted penis
and I got like more likes.
So it's just like whatever, yeah, but I'm-
- K-pop since you don't
mess with them, Joey
that's a universal truth.
- Yeah, I mean, I knew
that from the get go
but I didn't think that would
have caused a riot, right?
I'm just like, "Can these
people not take a joke?"
Clearly not anyway.
- Yeah, moving on.
So I see you started
Genshin, and I'm like, what?
- Oh, yeah.
- After holding off this
entire fucking time-
- Holding to the curve.
- And holding off from like
me and Joey talking about it
like every week.
- I didn't wanna spon...
Our fucking podcast to become
a sponsor episode for free.
If we're gonna talk about Genshin,
I wanna get fucking paid.
(both chuckling) you know what I mean?
- Do you like it though?
- Yeah, it's fine, it feels
like Breath of Wild light,
you know what I mean?
Like-
- [Both] Yeah.
- It feels like-
- It's die hard, Breath of the Wild.
- You know how like in Breath of the Wild
when you would like, think,
"Oh what if I do this weird thing?
And then you'd always
get rewarded for it?"
In Genshin I would be like,
"Oh, there's nothing there."
- Really?
- It's another common
chess, that won't bore you.
I don't understand what
I'm picking up but I-
- Because the reason I like Genshin,
and I've...
The reason I like it is that
it is very, very Breath of the Wild.
- Oh, yeah that's the
best part of the game.
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
but it's Breath of the
Wild mixed with basically
JRPG elements and I'm just like-
- That's fucking awful.
(both chuckles)
- See that, I was watching
this guy's stream.
Every time Python came on
screen, he was like, "Shut up!"
- There was like those one
point where it was a cut scene.
I think like, I just like
had my mouse to my head
and I was just tapping it, just like-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- 'Cause I was so bored,
The story is so shit.
Not that I would have
paid attention to anyway
but it's like doubly shit.
And then some people in my chat were like,
"Why are you skipping the cut scenes?"
And I'm like, "It's shit, right?"
And everyone's like,
"Yeah, it's kind of shit."
(Joey chuckling)
And I was like, okay, good,
then I'm skipping them all.
I don't know, that's like, it's boring.
I don't find any of these
characters interesting
'cause they're all gacha characters
and most of them are just, I don't know.
- I mean like the thing
with gacha game stories
is that they rarely start
off goods, you know?
If a gacha story gets
good, it's normally like
way into development where
like five chapters in
or like when they released
like their fifth story.
- Like chapter six Arknights.
- Yeah, which I've heard
about chapter six Arknights
so it was just meant to be
amazing and I'm just like,
well, I've kind of
skipped the entire story
up to this point, so-
- I just don't trust anyone with-
- I've read chapter one and that's it.
Like after that, I was
like, oh, okay, I don't need
to know this story to play the game.
- Yeah, I just don't understand people
who like love stories in gacha games.
I just, I mean, we've
covered this before but-
- Yeah.
- Have we?
I mean, we've covered
story in video games, yeah.
- But I mean, there are
specially shitty in gacha.
Like Breath of the Wild
didn't have much story
and I was like the best part of the game.
So like, just do what you want.
- Yeah, but like the reason
why people skipped over
fucking Breath of the Wild
story is because like,
what person doesn't know the
story of Legend of Zelda.
- What is the story of Breath of the Wild?
- Began it.
- Yeah, you just began it, right?
- That's nice though, I liked that.
They kept it simple, like, let me do it.
I mean, I like the fact that
you can change characters
and it's elemental and
the combat's kind of fun.
It's it's okay, it feels
pretty limited, but-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I mean that's fine.
- I mean, the reason
I thought it was great
was because it feels like Genshin is like,
kind of feels like a
first of its kind, right?
Because when you think of gacha games
and when you think of
the whole gacha genre,
you have this image of just like, you know
cheap mobile games that only
hardcore weaves are into.
And it's been really weird seeing just
how much Genshin has blown up.
And I feel like I went
into Genshin thinking,
"Oh, it's just gonna
be kind of like Honkai
but a little bit more polished."
And I got completely blown
away when I was just like,
No, this just feels like a AAA gacha game.
It feels like the very,
very first AAA gacha game
where it's like way more
polished than pretty much
any of its competition.
- Like, I didn't understand
why people liked Faygo,
like I saw Faygo, it looks-
- It's because of fate.
- It really looked like a mini clip game.
The art looked shit and then also
the story sounded like a convoluted mess.
And then also the gacha
rates were abysmal, so-
- Because you don't mess.
it's like, tide moon fans
like K-pop fans, right?
It's like the moment
there's anything tide moon
they are just like, "Give it to me."
- So, there's this thing called like
the waifu economy, right?
(gasping)
(chuckling)
Where it's the value of the waifus
and because those tide
moon have such like...
Because tide moon have such a strong brand
with fate and all the waifus in it
that just makes the waifus
and fate worth that much more.
And people look...
You look like you're about
to die inside right now.
- Garnt's a waifu economist.
(both laughing)
- It's like absurd.
- But like the story in
Faygo does actually get good
like fucking five chapters in.
I can't remember which chapter Camelot is
but that's when it gets good.
- So when you're playing the gacha games
do you want the characters
because you liked them
or because they'll make you OP?
- I mean, I'm sure it goes both ways.
- That's the eternal struggle, right?
Do you go with Metta or
do you go with waifu?
- I just want the OP ones,
I don't care about the characters looks.
- Oh, I'm completely the opposite.
'Cause like every time I stream Genshin,
there are so many back seater
for Genshin, Holy shit.
- There are two types
of people in this world.
- Yeah, there are so many
backseaters for Genshin,
where like, I think once I
had like both Qiqi and Klee
in like my party and people were like,
"What the fuck, that's like
the worst combination."
I'm like, I didn't give a shit
, I like these characters.
I just wanna play as
the characters I like,
I like these waifus.
- I honestly think like going
with the just the good
waifus is the way to go.
Because I feel like
going into a gacha game
wanting to be OP means that you kind of
go into the mentality where you wanna like
kind of complete the game,
you know what I mean?
You wanna optimize it, right?
- It's like going into a casino
expecting to be a millionaire, you know?
- No, you wanna complete the game,
wait, were we not completing the game?
Is that not what we are all doing?
Am I confused? Like-
- No, I mean, if you wanna comp-
- If you don't wanna complete the game.
- No, its not about-
- How can you complete a gacha game?
- Do the story.
- But the story is and
everything in a gacha game.
- Yeah.
- Okay, so you do the story
in Genshin, and then what?
Then what did you do?
- You go around exploring the world
or you collect all the characters or-
- Collect all the characters?
You mean gamble all your
fucking money away, like-
- Yes, welcome to gacha's Connor.
(Garnt chuckling)
That's the whole fucking point.
- No, once you have done all
the content in the game, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- What do you do then?
- Its like wait for the next update.
- But like, okay, that's where like,
when Arknights came out, right?
The white between those things
was just like a ticking time bomb of like,
"Am I gonna drop this game?"
- [Joey] Right.
- Because that wait period is like,
"How long can I reasonably
keep logging into this?"
Like to the point where I'm
like, "What am I doing?"
And obviously like, after X amount of time
when you've beaten the
game that's when it's like,
"Okay, I'm done, like,
I've played this game,
I've got my fill,
I don't need to spend
any more money on this,
I'll play something else."
- I find it really funny though
that you're the one who's like,
"No, I wanna finish the story."
As someone who does, no idea
what fuck the story is about.
- No, I wanna do all, like
the content, all the bosses
like all the fun aspects,
and normally, unfortunately
it's tied to the story.
- 'Cause I remember-
- Fortunately all the boss
fights are tied to a story.
- It's like seeing you enter
like discover Arknights
for the first time and seeing
you like your first entrance
into the world of gacha.
I'm just like, "I see him."
I just saw you spiraling down into hell.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I saw you were like,
"Oh man I wanna collect this.
I wanna level up this character.
I wanna level up that character,
I wanna optimize this."
I'm like, "Oh no, you're gonna
be spending a lot of money."
- Well, that's 'cause I wanted to,
unfortunately with Arknights
there will always be that
one stage, Arknights is like
a tower defense kind of game.
- Please, sponsor us.
- And basically, there was...
No matter how many OP characters you had
their always come a stage,
when you will need like
one specific character
that had this one niche
that you didn't have.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It was super annoying when it happened.
So I just wanted to spec everything
And everything we've had on every stage
and then yeah, I just
gave up and I thought-
- Yeah, which is what I was saying.
Like, if you want to
complete a gacha game,
you are gonna have a bad time because-
- I felt like I completed
Arknights, like I did everything.
- I mean, there's always
new content coming out.
You never reach-
- That was now-
- The only time you can
complete a gacha game
is when the developers just stop.
- Giving a shit, yeah.
- But this is the thing, right?
If, when you have done
everything in a game, right?
And then say the next patch
coming out in a month.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like, are you then happy
to stop playing that game
before the new chapters
come out next month?
Are you done?
- Which is why, I feel like
this is a super interesting
conversation because I feel like
a lot of people wins the
Genshin and they like
I don't think even Genshin,
is kind of expected
the kind of response
that it would have gotten
and how popular it would have gotten,
because this is like a lot of
people's first introduction
into gacha games, right?
And there's been like a big controversy
with Gentian stamina system
when you reach end game, right?
When you kind of complete the
story, explore everything.
- So, is the stamina is for
running around, swimming,
and climbing, right?
- No, so you haven't used
stamina in Genshin yet.
- Oh, I haven't, okay.
- No, so you understand...
Okay, so every gacha game has
kind of like a stamina system
where normally you
spend a resource to play
some certain aspects of the game, right?
Genshin to me, I feel like
it's super weird, right?
'Cause you can go, you could
play it for like 30 plus hours
and never have to use
stamina system at all.
Whereas with like Arknights has sanity.
You kind of like, reach the stamina cap
within like a week of playing it all out,
I'd say right?
Same thing like Faygo.
I can't remember what the stamina
system in Faygo is called,
but in Genshin the stamina
system is called resin.
And you use resin whenever
you like go complete a dungeon
or don't go like flights and bosses.
Now when you're in the early game
and when you're just exploring the world
you can just not use the
stamina system at all
because their is so much to
do and the world is like...
The world is fucking massive, right?
- Yeah.
- The world is absolutely massive
that you could spend 30 plus
hours exploring the world
doing everything in the
world, doing story quest
and not have to like focus on grinding
and leveling up your
characters and doing bosses
and everything, but once
you reach the end game,
once you've explored everything,
then their is nothing to do
but grind out and you know, and try to...
And just use resin.
And the argument is,
from what I understand,
'cause I haven't actually
reach end game myself
there is just no enough resin,
to give yo meaningful content
once you've reached
the end of the content.
- I don't understand
people who like just grind.
Like we'll play a game
for hours and end on grind
when there's no guarantee
that anything's coming.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like that's like psychotic to me.
- Yeah, because I've
heard that the best way
to like enjoy Genshin, from
what I've heard from people
who have reached end game already is that,
you shouldn't rush through the game.
- No, you shouldn't.
- Because getting to end game is actually
much quicker than a lot of people expect.
And then once you hit that point,
and once you have to start
using the stamina system
then it's like you are really
limited to what you can do.
- Yeah, you are really limited to content.
And that's why I think Genshin is like
the super unique example,
because most gacha games,
it's just like a mobile
game where you just like,
you can play it for
like five to 10 minutes,
when it pop sometimes, you know
you rarely play for long period of time.
Whereas with Genshin because
it feels more like a AAA game.
People wanna play this for hours on end.
And people are coming in expecting
this to be like an MMORPG
where you're just like constantly grinding
and constantly doing something.
And this is like infinite content, right?
- Mm.
- I just find that MMORPG is so boring.
after like X level, when
you start grinding, I just-
- [Both] Yeah.
- I don't know, like I think
some people can do grinding,
no problem, but for me it's like just-
- I'm on new JRPG, so.
- Yeah, I mean, I just
like, I think it's like,
why would you just stop
me from having fun?
Like, (Garnt chuckling)
I don't understand.
- Some people find grinding really fun.
- Yeah.
- I think it's like
relaxing for some people.
- Yeah, I find it relaxing.
- For me, it's just like, I
feel like you're just like
taking the out of me.
Like you're just kind of making
a mockery of my time here.
Like, you are making me do all this thing-
- You are only making
me use 1% of my brain.
- Almost, it's like, you know, some,
when I used to play RuneScape,
like I didn't mind it,
but I was also fucking 12 and
I was just dumb little shit.
And I wouldn't mind taking on.
I literally spent like
hours a day clicking trees.
I can't even believe I did that.
- But like MMOs by yourself
or were you playing it with friends?
- I had friends as well, but still it...
But like-
- 'Cause I mean, I
couldn't be able to grind
in MMO by myself.
- Like raids look fun
in World of Warcraft.
When they are eight people communicating,
like that looks fun, but I
also don't want to get there,
because the points of getting
there are insane, right?
- [Both] Yeah.
- But my little brother was
addicted to World of Warcraft
and he fucking, you
couldn't get him off it.
- I never got into all Wold of Warcraft.
- I've never been into.
I don't think I've played
like a single MMORPG because-
- Wait, not even RuneScape?
- I didn't even play RuneScape, no.
- I fucking loved RuneScape,
I spent so many hours on the game.
- Yeah.
- I just like beg my parents
when I was like 14 like,
"Please, mother, please
pay for membership.
It's only five pounds a month."
- Seriously, I couldn't.
I didn't have the balls to
ask my parents to do that,
so that's why I was like, no.
- I think it was like for
my birthday, I was like,
"Can I have RuneScape for a year?"
(both chuckling)
And they were like, "Yeah."
And obviously when you were like 14
time doesn't go nearly as
fast as it does now, right?
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Right.
- So I remember like the first month
I played like eight hours a
day of RuneScape every day.
I was so addicted.
- True gaming goal right here.
- Yeah, and when I got
like 17, I stopped playing,
I gave my account to my little brother,
'cause he wanted to play
on it for a little bit.
Then fucking lost all my shit.
(Garnt chuckling)
I remember there was like
this thing called like...
There was this thing you had to grind
for like the specific armor
and it took like months
and he'd lost it.
- Like missile armor or some shit.
- It was like called Fist
of Gothics or something.
I don't know what it was called.
(chuckling)
- Fist of Gothics.
- It was like this hummer
where you had to play
it's like an egg game, it was really dumb.
I would spent like two weeks straight
getting this hummer,
doing these mini games
and then he lost it and
then I got up again.
I came out of retirement from
RuneScape, just to get this-
(chuckling)
- You came out of retirement.
- I came out of RuneScape retirement,
just to get this hummer again
and he fucking lost it again.
And I was like, "That's it
I'm done with RuneScape."
- You pulled like a high misogyny, right?
I'm coming out to RuneScape
to save this company.
(all laughing)
- I couldn't believe it.
But going in to gacha, like
I'm so quick to drop games
because at the moment the
game is boring, even remotely.
Like if I have one gaming session
where I'm playing the game
and I just didn't have any
fun, I'm like, "All right, well
I'm done with that game."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Somehow League of
Legends hasn't done that.
I mean, I think it's like hacked my brain.
I don't know why, I hate it.
- I feel like it has hacked
your brain in such sense.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I don't know.
Do you enjoy league or do you feel like-
- League of Legends by the way, I'm sure-
- Did you actually enjoy
league or do you just
sometimes play it because it's just like-
- To copy me.
- It's like a familiar kind of like system
that you just understand and-
- I think, I don't know.
Joey probably hasn't had this, but I think
when you've played a game
like that for so long,
there is just kind of like
almost autopilot nature to it
where like I'll see, I
have like an hour free.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And I'll just click it open
even though every time I know
when I click it open,
it's a bad idea because
not only will I probably
not have a good game.
If I have a good game, I
don't feel good about it
'cause I'm like, "Well that
was a stomp, that was no fun."
- [Garnt] Yeah, exactly.
- But if I lose or have someone entering
or on the Japanese
server I've been playing,
people just fucking trolls
so much more, it's so bad.
And I'll be like, "Wow,
I just wasted 30 minutes
and now I'm fucking angry."
And then I know every time I click it open
It's never gonna be worth it
but sometimes I still do it.
- Because it's like just habit building.
- I have played League of Legends.
Like it's been like, I'd
say my main game for...
God, when did Dilution
come out? Like 2004?
- Jesus Christ man.
- Like, it's been like six, seven years.
I've just like, its for the game
that I always just go back to,
and it used to be really fun,
but now it's just like depressing.
I don't know, that's why I like-
- It's so funny, you're speaking to people
who've played league for years.
'Cause everyone talks about
it like they are fucking
drug addicts, like-
- it's certainly sounds like it.
- Like you know, "I wanna
quit, but I just can't man.
I just can't, I need..."
- The side effects.
- "There's something about me,
I just need to play one more
game, just one more game.
(Joey chuckling)
But I just can't quit.
I can't quit, damn it."
- It used to be like,
back when I lived in...
When I was in university,
it was really easy
to just play with people
and it was pretty fun.
'Cause I was used to play for
the university team as well.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- It was pretty fun actually,
I really enjoyed that.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But then when I left
university, I went to London.
I wasn't really playing
as much with friends.
And then I set the bridge
to Japan it's totally
like a solo queue thing,
which it's just isn't fun.
Which solo queue is
just playing on your own
with four other random people.
And I don't know why
in the Japanese civil,
it's so bad dude.
It's full of like Chinese
Smurfs and Korean Smurfs
who wanna just fuck around,
all the deans are horrible.
- So then have you considered-
- Quitting?
- Stopping?
- It's hard, man.
- It's because I know why.
Its because there's nothing
to replace it, right?
- What do you do, right?
What do you do when you have
like just one hour free?
Just only one hour free?
- Jack off.
(Garnt chuckling)
- For one hour?
- I mean, I'll get the job
done within that hour, right?
And then-
- Connor's like, that's
an unoptimized jack off.
You can't have that.
- Well you know?
- No jack off should take
more than five minutes.
- Then, yeah, I have 55 minutes
to do whatever I want, right?
- But like, okay, now but
seriously, what do you do?
Like read a book, watch something?
- Yeah, read a book usually.
- I can't open a book
for an hour, I'd stuck
- Yeah, 'cause you are
a fucking monkey brains.
- Its like an eight hour
thing for me if I open a book.
- Eight hours?
- I have to make it a
whole day thing if I read.
- I'm talking about
like, like manga or like-
- Yeah, manga.
- I'm actually with Connor.
- Really?
- Like if I'm reading manga,
it has to be a whole day thing.
I can't put it down.
- Oh, no, I can easily
just pick up a volume,
read it and then that's it.
- Yeah.
- I think the problem is
that league is so easy
to just do for 30
minutes without engaging.
- It just engages that monkey brain,
that fucking lizard brain
where you just like,
"Okay, I'm just clicking buttons now."
- Yeah, and I recognize
that it invalidates
a lot of my points, like when we talk
about fighting games.
- Yeah.
- That clip of us talking
about it and me being like,
"Yeah, fuck it." You know?
- Yeah.
- I got so much shit for that.
'Cause one first of all, they were like
"Well Connor's a league player,
So it makes so much sense."
And then the other top comments are like,
"Connor's is just a sore loser,
that's why he doesn't
like fighting games."
I'm like, "You don't
know a true fucking loss
until you've played a
40 minute game of league
and your team fucking threw it all.
- This video is sponsored by Honey.
Imagine this, you make a
list of gifts you gonna buy
for the holidays, and then
someone randomly gives you
the money to help buy one, sounds good.
Well, that's what honey is doing.
They're helping pay for
$1 million worth of gifts.
$1 million?
- That's a lot of money.
- You're probably wondering,
is this the same honey
that automatically searches
for promo codes online?
- I am wondering, is it?
- Yes. Yes it is Joey.
With honey, you can
also make a list of all
the holiday gifts you
want from certain stores
and Honey will email you when
their price drops on anything.
- Anything?
- On your list, any thing.
- Just add honey to your
computer, create a free account
and throw some holiday
gifts in your drop list
for a chance to win.
Honey will randomly select winners
and give them the money to help
buy something on their list.
They basically turn into Santa.
- I would like a copy of
super Mario all-stars please,
honey, that's on my drop list by the way.
Why are you laughing Joey,
it's on my drop list.
- Honey, I want the new
X-Box, you know which one.
- Did you know, there is
no purchase necessary.
You need a PayPal account
to redeem the price
only in the U.S. and the giveaway ends
on the 21st of December 2020, so go now.
- You don't even need to
be a good boy or good girl
to get all the gifts
that honey can give you.
Get honey today for free at
JOINHONEY.COM/TRASHTASTE.
That's JOINHONEY.COM/TRASHTASTE.
- Back to the episode.
Yeah, there's a lot of
people who are saying,
"Yeah, I'm just bad at fighting
games and I'm a sole loser,
that's why I don't like to do it.
And it's so bullshit.
If you had played league, you
know what true fucking pain
is like, I would rather lose
a two minute fighting game
any day of the week than
lose one league game.
'Cause it is brutal.
- I mean, just from the sounds of it,
it just sounds like a shit experience.
- Oh, it is, it's terrible.
It's fucking awful.
- Then stop.
- Who knows man, just say
that to a crack addict, Joey.
- I will.
- Just tell him to search-
- Well, you can quit
crack, just do League.
- It is like crack because I will say like
the honeymoon period of league,
like when you first
start learning the game
and when you start
clicking, it's probably like
some of my fondest gaming
experiences in my life
when I'm just like, "This is
a really, really fun game."
And it's just like, it is-
- I didn't even get to that point.
'Cause I played one game
and then five minutes in
all the comments and called
me new fan and it kept me, so-
- So tell me like, what did you hate
about League of Legends?
Like walk me throw it?
- I mean, well, first of all,
I don't like MOBAs to begin with.
- Yeah, I mean like they
are assertive context.
- Yeah, so yeah, so that was that.
And then just again, like,
just from what I've seen
and from what I've heard from a distance
the league community just looks like
a bunch of fucking cocks.
(Garnt laughing)
- What do you mean by a bunch of cocks?
- It's like they just, you
know, I've always hated
using the word gate
keeping but, oh my God!
League players are like
the crowns of gate keeping.
Like you say anything bad about the game.
You try and get into it,
like with no experience
or no knowledge of the game whatsoever.
Most communities will, you
know at least a few of them
will be like, "Hey you're
trying to get into our game,
welcome, we'll invite you with open arms.
But if you suck at the game
then that's your responsibility, right?"
And I'm like, all right, fair enough.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But meanwhile league is
like you're not a fucking God
at this game from five minutes in
then you're a new fan get out.
- It's-
- That was my experience with league.
- I mean, league definitely
has one of the most
toxic communities.
- Yeah.
- I actively tell people like
just don't get into league,
it's not like it's not rewarding.
- Yeah, and I'm like, I already can't deal
with fucking toxic
communities to begin with.
- Yeah.
- I guess I don't really mind that much.
Like I kind of liked that aspect of games.
- I've been on the internet for too long.
I don't wanna deal with that anymore.
- Connor is like a toxic gamer.
- I have to deal with the
anime community, right?
Like let alone the league community.
- I know, what do you
think about the argument
that like a lot of people get really upset
with the idea of like trash
talking video games online.
Like, what do you think about that?
- I think if it's done
tastefully, I don't really-
- Yeah, like whenever
I see you trash talking
like the fighting game
community, I'm like,
"Ah, that's just fun."
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Yeah,
it's kinda sad 'cause I feel
like in League of Legends,
not... I mean, it's obviously
there are some people
who say some fucking APAR and stuff.
- Yeah.
- But like, I think just, you know
like fucking telling the
other team that Baton stuff
is funny as hell, like I'm not doing that.
- Oh yeah, if it's done tasteful, right?
- Yeah.
- And which is, there's
many ways to do that.
- Just as long as you're not like
attacking someone personally.
- [Both] Yeah.
- I think it's like, I'm all game for it.
Like if someone, if I do a terrible job
in League of Legends game,
maybe fuck something up
I fucking hope they type
and they all chat to me
saying like, "LOL" or
something, you know what I mean?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Because that's funny
to me, like I want that.
- Because you do the same, right?
- Oh, a hundred percent.
- But if it gets to like, you know some
racial xenophobic shit, then
I'm just like, "All right-"
- Oh, that's fucked up, yeah.
- Please stop.
- I mean, obviously I think
there was a draw on the line,
but obviously kind of feels
like, especially in league
that they've like kind
of like cracked down
on anything like that.
- But I feel like they had
to, because it was so far
removed from what was
acceptable, that you're like,
you go into like a normal
game and people are still
toxic as fuck, even
though it's a normal game.
- The problem was that he
never enforced any of the rules
for so long, so it just kept escalating.
And I reckon if they enforced
like the actual rules
from the beginning, it
wouldn't have been so bad.
- [Joey] You are right.
- I mean, yeah.
- But I feel like this
is like the same cycle
for every competitive
game, you what I mean?
Without exception, I
mean, you can seem like-
- I played Overwatch as well-
- Yeah, you look at
Overwatch, and it's like
the first few months, great.
Everyone had fucking fun.
Everyone was just learning the game.
And then like, it's the
problem of when you've played
the game enough, you don't
play because it's fun.
You play because like you said,
it's just something to do.
- And then out from the
shadows rose the try-hard.
(Garnt chuckling)
- Dude, I had some of
the worst experiences
of my life on Overwatch.
- Did you actually?
- Because League of Legends, right.
It's bad, right, it's bad.
It's, you see them
violet shit, but at least
there's no voice chat.
In Overwatch, you're automatically
put in like voice chat
with your team.
- That sounds horrible.
- Well, okay.
Sometimes you'd have like
the funniest moments ever
like you would meet the coolest people.
And it was like, you'd
always have to remember that
whenever you got like
the 10 games in a row
of like fucking kids and shit.
- [Both] Right.
- Because like as well the
worst part is an Overwatch
when I used to play it they
implemented a system now
where you can queue up for a role,
but it used to be six of you got put in
you all might be six tank mains.
You all might be six, like DPS mains.
So you'd stop fucking
bickering immediately
over who gets what?
And that's why I always
just play, fill in games.
Like, I'll just do
whatever, 'cause I'm like,
"I don't fucking care,
like don't shout at me,
let's just do it man."
- [Both] Yeah.
- But man, people would
like say horrible shit
on that, like always 12 year olds as well.
- I mean, because once
you play it enough hours
then you've reached this
point where you're like,
"Okay I got to play ranks,
because otherwise playing
this game is kind of like
meaningless in a sense, right?
- I hate playing normal games
of like competitive games.
- Yeah, but then when,
once you start getting
on the ranks ladder is when I
find it, it stops getting fun
because then you reach and
everyone reaches a wall.
Doesn't matter who you are
everyone will reach a wall eventually.
And once you reached that wall
you just feel like you stop progressing.
Unless you put like so many
hours into learning this game
and trying to better
yourself and at that point
I understand why people
get toxic and angry.
- Yeah.
- Because then the weight
they like to invest into
like making that...
Like climbing up the ranks
ladder and everything.
So they feel like they
need this to feel like
they haven't wasted there time.
Which let's be honest,
unless you're a programmer
you probably are wasting
your time with it.
- You know what it might be?
I think it's just the simple thing that
I can just not into
PVP with random people.
- Really?
- I think that's all it is.
Like, I'm thinking about it now.
I'm like, I've never enjoyed
just PVP games to begin with.
Maybe for the exception of
like some fighting games
but only if I'm like playing
it with friends I know.
- Right.
- So like, I'll play like a game of Smash
or like straight fight or
old tech in or whatever
if I'm sitting in the same room with you
and we just like having a
fun fucking time, right?
But I think just the whole idea of PVP
against randos on the internet,
who I don't know or care about,
I think that's just the one thing
I fucking hate in gaming.
- Why is Garnt laughing?
- I just have this like
image of Joey being like,
"I have fun with friends."
And then I think like the
angriest I've ever seen Joey
is when you're playing against Connor
and he was like, spamming
King K. Rool at your house
and I'm just like (chuckling)
- No, but that's the thing, right.
I'm okay with getting angry
in situations like that
because I know Connor and he's
there in front of me, right?
Like, so like, that's
just fun times, right?
Like, yeah, I was off that you
were spamming fucking counsel
with King K. Rool, every fucking match.
- Joey gets very, very angry
when he loses in the Smash.
- Yeah, but that's what I'm saying though.
It's like, I don't like
PVP games as it is.
Like, I'm not a huge fan of PVP as it is
because I get angry easily.
But especially when it's
against people, I can't see,
or I've never heard of, never
talked to, just don't know.
- Yeah.
- That anger, I think...
Yeah, that just like the
enjoyment is just completely gone.
- I remember you were like,
"Yeah, man, I'm the best.
No, one's beat me at Mario Kart ever."
Like Joey is like-
- I did not say that, you are a lair.
- You were like I never
lose him Mario Kart-
- You are the absolute slander.
(both chuckling)
I did not say that.
- It was like some fake news-
- It was something along those lines.
You were like, "I never
losing Mario Kart."
And then I was like, "Bet."
And then like, Joey
would bit all his friends
and I would just crush Joey.
- Okay, crush is a strong word.
(Garnt chuckling)
- But in recent times, you've been playing
and it's been pretty 50, 50, but yeah,
when it was like, which one was it?
- It's probably when Deluxe came out,
the new Mario Kart eight,
I was fucking killing Joey.
- Yeah, I think so.
- And had him made like,
he can't game play.
Ethan, like a fucking breakdown.
Do you remember that?
We did like a stream where
we kept playing Mario Kart.
- I only played baby
park for like five hours.
- Until Ethan could beat me
and we must've played it
yeah for like five hours
until he managed to bit me.
- We did like 150 fucking time.
We did a baby park 150 times
on stream, we were like,
"All right, let's like
after like race 20 rool."
We were like, "All right, if
Ethan beats Connor in one race,
then we'll run the stream.
- Yeah, and then that was also earlier on
that they thought I was
cheating or something.
- Yeah, your doom was like,
"He's got a modern suite
or something like, he's
winning too many times."
- Yeah, so they made us all
change to the same character
in the same car and everything like,
so there was no cheating at all,
like it was all the same thing.
And he was like, "How
are you still beating me
every time?"
(Joey chuckling)
It was so funny.
- See, that's like, those
kinds of like competitive games
I fucking love, right.
Like, I don't wanna say
the word party games.
But like, I mean, they are party games.
Like that's why I fucking
love about party games,
is that yeah, you'll get
people who are fucking salty
and it is PVP technically.
But at the end of the day,
it's fucking whatever.
It's a fucking Mario Kart game, right?
- What do you think of people throwing
their controllers, Joey?
- Huh?
- What do you think about
people throwing controllers?
- I mean, I've done it before as well.
- Actually.
- Yeah, I've done it in Smash, remember?
- Did you really?
- Yeah.
- But I think it's so cringe, (chuckling)
no matter how angry I get, I'll be like,
"But not you."
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Put that there.
(all chuckling)
- Okay, to be fair, I only did it once.
- But you see that's an
expensive fucking Joey,
Connor is like, "I aint
throwing these things.
- Oh no, I threw it like
the really cheap shit,
like GameCube controller.
- Oh those budget ones, oh.
- Were just like 15 bucks.
It's like the budget one, it's
like even if I break this,
I can buy another one, it's fine, but the-
- The YouTuber money is-
- Pad control, I would never.
and that's too much of an expensive...
Like, Oh my God, seeing
like Smash compilations
of like people just absolutely
just shocking their controllers.
- I do love watching Smash
tournament rage moments.
- Oh, it's so funny.
I'm like, dude, it's a
party game like just chill.
- Yeah, but like I was about to ask
what'd you think about party games?
I mean, do you see Smash as a party game?
- Yeah, I mean-
- Bro, you got a (indistinct)
- Dude, Sakurai himself
said it was a party game.
So it's a fucking party game, all right?
- It's a party game that
can be played competitively.
is, can also be competitive.
- Imagine like musical chairs.
If there was a pro league-
- Yeah.
- Yeah, (laughing)
I can't wait for the
salt in the comments man.
I cannot Wait for the
salt in the comments.
- I mean, look, it's
like, I'm not saying that,
you know, Smash is not a competitive game.
Like it absolutely is.
I fucking love watching the
competitive scene of Smash pros.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- But, but it's a competitive
game that can also
be a party, you know?
Like again, like if you
said for example, right.
If fucking Mario Kart
had like a pro league,
then yeah, it could probably
be a competitive game
but it doesn't.
- Why doesn't it though? Why?
Okay, here's why I've never understand,
how did Smash get so competitive
as opposed to basically like
every other Nintendo game?
- I think, because a lot of
them are like too random.
Like Mario Kart has way
too many random aspects.
- Right.
- Where I think like-
- That's why I like Smash,
like Smash competitive
is like no items final destination only-
- That's right, they literally
knew called the randomization
from it, right?
- Right.
- So even the stages
they can't move, right?
- Yeah, so the only, like...
I think the only way that something
like Mario Kart could
ever be competitive is if-
- No items?
- it's the same course, no items,
(Garnt chuckling)
and everyone is-
- Baby park.
- Same course, no items,
everyone's in the same character
with the same car.
- That'd be so fucking boring.
- Yeah, and that's the
only reason why, right?
- Yeah, I guess so.
- But again, like, you know
I'm sure there's lots
of party games out there
that could very easily be
considered competitive games.
- Like what?
- Guitar hero.
- Yeah.
- I mean, that's just
the way, that should go
into rhythm games right?
- That was actually competitive.
- Yeah, that's what I thought about that.
- Rhythm games can very
easily be competitive games,
but they are not,
because there's like
no real league for it.
But I reckon the only
reason why Smash became
a competitive game is
because of all the fucking
street fighter games.
- I feel like also it's just a nice
spectator sports as well.
'Cause I feel like with competitive games,
if there's gonna be a league for it,
it's got to be interesting
to watch, I'd say.
I feel like that's why
league is the biggest e-sport
because while I'd hardly
ever play league anymore
I still fucking watch it every year,
'cause it is a really fun game to watch
as opposed to-
- Because there's so much going on.
- Yeah, exactly.
And it feels like it was,
it feels like it's a game
that's designed to also be viewed as well
from a third person perspective.
- I mean, I used to, when the Overwatch
was doing the pro league
my friends used to watch it
but I used to watch it and
I'm like, what the is this?
I played this game and
there's way too much going on.
The quality was can't possibly
describe what's going,
because all the action happens so fast
and it's six different people
doing six different things.
Whereas the league it's
normally, if it's a team fight
it's still like, you can still
tell people what's going on.
- Yeah, its because of the top-down view
as opposed to Overwatch where just like
first person is here.
- It gets nociating.
- Yeah.
- Fucking be following
tracer, Tracer zooms back,
and then I switch into the
next guy and switch in again.
It's like, "Oh, just fuck me."
Like, and also I feel that
because of the length of league
you can sit down and enjoy.
And like I think the one
reason I've really gotten
to fighting games is that
normally when I'm watching
I mean, e-sports that's what I'm saying,
when I'm watching the e-sports,
I normally only watch like the finals
'cause I can kind of
follow what's going on.
It's like the Semi's and the finals
and it's really easy to follow along.
But when the group stages are going on
it's like, all right, "Who's this guy?"
And by the time I'm finished Googling him
the next guy's on fighting.
I'm like, "All right, well,
okay, who's this guy?"
And then the fight maybe I wanted to watch
he's over in three minutes and it's like,
"Okay, well I guess,
yeah, I guess that's it.
I guess all the fights
are over, okay, shit."
League is quite a long thing
and they've got a really
good system with the league
where it plays like two...
There's like every league
plays everyday now.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Like alternates on season.
- I mean it's-
- It's crazy, they got set
up literally like a football.
- Yeah, it's way more like
just a football, you know,
like a traditional sports now
where you can kind of like
jump in and jump out
and see familiar faces
and kind of like familiar
brands every time.
And I feel like that's kind of helped...
It's like the e-sports scene in league,
it just seems to keep growing every year,
which is fucking insane
to me that it's like
fucking 10, 11 years old now.
How old is league?
- 10.
- Yeah, and it's still
like growing each year
internationally, which-
- Shows the e-sports-
- Yeah, the e-sport which shows the power.
But like totally, I enjoy
watching fighting games as well.
- [Connor] Me too.
- Like, the only time I ever get into
is during like Evo or like the big kind of
- Yeah, true, Whatever else, like,
Oh, why is there a
million views on Twitch?
Oh, its Evo, okay, cool.
- Like I don't go around
like fucking looking for like
you know, local cons doing,
you know, Smash tournaments.
Like I'm not gonna watch those live
but you know, but yeah, like
Evo and fucking you know,
those big Smashtournament
are fucking fun to watch.
- The sponsor of today's
video is EJ Anime store.
- EJ Anime store, is an online mode store
that is run directly by Kodakawa.
Once again, they brought us an assortment
of special figures.
- Oh, look at this shit, look at this.
- You can't get these outside of Japan
because they can only be
purchased at EJ Anime tore.
- Tell us what we got today Connor.
- So, we have-
- Was this your first rodeo or something?
Like come on, bro.
- I just didn't have what EJ stood for.
I just kind of didn't know what to-
- I'll tell you, look into my eyes.
Entertainment, Japan.
- Okay, this in the middle
wearing the wedding dress
I assume is the Taiga Aisaka
wedding version from Toradora.
I can't see the face, I love Toradora.
- Very nice.
- Celebrating the 50th
anniversary of Toradora
light novel series.
We bring you the main heroine Taiga Aisaka
dressed in a beautiful
white wedding dress.
- Not only that but this
special set includes
an original F three size
canvas art signed by the author
of the original light novel
series Takemiya Yuyuko,
as an exclusive bonus.
- Out of here, Joey, that is the deal.
- Additionally, the figure also
includes extra exchangeable
face parts, showing Taiga loving games.
- And in original illustration
with a signature board signed
by the original illustrator
Yasu as a bonus.
- That's pretty freaking Epic.
(Connor chuckling)
But I'll tell you one thing
that I'm genuinely excited about,
It's the Slayer's sign, I
fucking love slayers dude.
- I can't believe we are
celebrating the 30th anniversary
of the Slayers light novel.
- Okay, to be actually honest with you.
I can't fucking believe
it's 30 years already.
- I know.
- 'Cause I grew up reading
Slayers and I'm like,
"Man, this is such a new show."
I realized it started before I was born.
But we have the Lina
Inverse kimono version,
which is again, celebrating
the 30th anniversary
of the Slayers light novel series.
And the special set includes a
B2 tapestry of the originally
created illustration
that inspired this figure
as an exclusive bonus, as
you can see right here.
- Look at that.
- It looks very nice.
- Then we also got to the
(speaking foreign language)
and that was a fucking mouthful.
- Oh, Kimisen.
(both chuckling)
- Did you just name a town in Wales?
So this is the Aliceliese
original dress version.
- And finally we have the "Date A Live 3"
Tohka Yatogamy Chinese
style dress version.
- You nailed that pronunciation, Joey.
Goddamn dude.
- Would you believe me if I
told you that I know Japanese?
- If you like any of these figures
be sure to go check them
out at ejanimestore.com
or click the link in the
description down below.
- They are writing new
stuff on a regular basis,
so stay tuned to there
updates and look them up
on Twitter and Facebook.
- Back to the video.
- As the host of this episode.
(Joey laughing)
Why are you laughing?
I'm the host Joey, come on.
- What does it feel like?
- Power, it's the power, I
guess are we anime podcast?
(chuckling)
- Wow, what a question?
- I was wondering this yesterday.
I was like, I see people
on Twitter or Reddit.
They talk about like,
"Oh man, I like it when
they talk about anime,
I don't like it when
they talk about anime."
I guess it's weird, 'cause
I guess when we started,
it was like I guess we said
we were the animated podcast-
- Well, our channel bio
I think is a terrible anime podcast.
If you go on our about
section that's what it says.
- I always never gave a
fuck that much about anime.
- Wow, just come out and say it.
- Yeah, no, I always had
a genuine question for you
which is, do you see yourself
as an anime YouTuber?
- The thing is I think
because I see myself
in the same like realm.
- Yeah.
- With like those people.
- 'Cause you hang out with us, right?
- I hanging out with you
guys, I watch a lot of anime.
I make it, I think because I
make so many anime references
and there's so much like anime
and like this Otaku culture
in my videos, I guess I do.
But not in the traditional sense.
Like, 'cause like I don't
make videos about anime-
- Yeah.
- But that's the thing, right?
It's like nowadays you make
any content, that's like,
even if you make content
that's just like general
or Otaku shit like you or hockey.
- Yeah.
- Just because like I think
Otaku just equals anime now.
- Well, I think that the
people who watch my stuff
are people who consume anime.
- [Joey] Right.
- [Garnt] Right.
- But I'm not necessarily
talking about anime.
- I know it's weird, right?
Because I've been like
as the OG anime YouTuber,
it's so weird seeing anime
content on YouTube nowadays.
And this is just me thinking
out loud, but do people even
want to see as much like
anime content as much anymore?
And 'cause I feel like it's
been really weird seeing content
on anime content on YouTube
in 2020, where it feels like
anime content doesn't even
perform that amazingly anymore.
Compared to doing like
anime themed content,
as opposed to,
"I am going to make
content on a certain show."
- It's Otaku content now.
- Yeah.
- I mean, when we started the podcasts,
I was kind of worried,
I was like, Fuck it.
They're going to like wanna
talk about anime every week
'cause I call it.
- I mean, is that is technically speaking.
That is what we sought out to do.
- Yeah, 'cause I remember
when we were discussing it,
I remember in my head, I'm like,
"I'm just gonna like
bring up all this stuff.
We'll just see how it does, right?"
Like it could have backfired so much.
- It's funny because the only
time I talked about anime most
is on the podcast with you guys, right?
Rarely do we actually talk
about anime off screen?
- Yeah.
- I feel like there's more people like,
I guess if you want to get into it like
more people are way qualified
than us, to talk about it.
Like just consuming anime, all
they do is talk about anime.
But I also, in my opinion like
when I do wanna consume stuff
about anime, I often don't
want that kind of person,
who's just like, all they do is anime,
I kind of want like a monkey
brain person kind of opinion.
- Like a personality who
also love anime, right?
- I just want someone...
Which is why like I think
the only anime reviews
I still watch which weird to say is,
I watch Critical reviews
because I know that when I'm getting that,
I'm getting a review from someone-
- Oh, that's also like
someone like Critical
can pretty much just
do content on anything.
- But I think because I've
been on YouTube for so long
and I've been throughout all
of my anime watching lifespan,
if you will.
- Yeah.
Whenever I wanted to see
if I wanted to watch a show
I would just go and watch
a review from someone
who all they do is talk about anime.
All they do is consume
anime, Otaku culture.
And it's just really refreshing to now go
and watch someone who doesn't really care
that much about anime but
they do like it a lot.
- Like it's not their entire life.
- Right, like it's just
like, I'm a normal guy.
I do things, but I also
watch a lot of anime.
- Yeah, I feel like that
attitude really reflects
on how you know,
how anime content performs
on YouTube as well,
it's because I feel like
if you only do anime
content and you like only...
I feel like because anime has gotten
so much more mainstream
in the past few years
it's not so much about being an anime fan.
You know what I mean?
Like there are definitely
channels that's, you know,
I'm probably like one of the biggest
where you focus solely on anime.
But I feel like there
you hit a ceiling, right?
You hit the ceiling of,
okay, if you only target
yourself towards anime fans
that community now is only so big,
but anime as a medium is
actually bigger than just
the anime community.
'Cause like you can be
like a true anime fan
follow seasonal anime
and everything like that.
But then there's like
a way bigger community
that knows about anime and you know,
watches the old anime show.
But they also don't have as
much of a vested interest.
- Are you eight from that nomie guy?
(Garnt laughing)
- Maybe I'm talking about nomies.
Like they don't have a vested interest
or they're not as invested.
- I basically gonna sum it up,
I like watching nomies reviews.
I should have said that.
- It's the difference between anime fans
and people who are fans of anime.
I feel there's like a
big difference, right?
'Cause like an anime fan is
like someone where it's like
anime is their life.
Like they love everything about it.
They'll watch anything, they'll
dedicate their life to it.
And then there are fans
of anime where it's like-
- I got the perfect word for this.
There are anime fans and
then there are weebs.
(all chuckling)
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, you are right.
- You are just so fucking proud of that.
- I'm just like, I figured it out.
I figured out the system.
- All right, you got it.
- Yeah.
- So just disregard
everything I just said.
- No, because, somebody is like,
as you were saying out-
- That's why I said that
like we like what you say,
we are weebs-
- Yeah, we are weebs, 'cause
like I was thinking to myself
like what differentiates
someone like Critical
from someone like in the anime community
because, it made me think,
remember the good old days
of gate keeping and be-
- You mean 2020?
- Yeah, (chuckling) and
like the old days where like
you're not a true anime fan
unless you've watched XXX show.
(Joey chuckling)
- Yeah.
- Like, oh, you're an anime fan,
name me 20 different
shows that are now return-
- You are an anime fan
link me on my anime.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Then every anime on what Joey has done.
- I've done that.
- But I'm like, it's good that nowadays
I feel like gate keeping
especially in the anime community,
it's like, it's not died
but it's definitely way less
than it used to be.
But I feel like someone like Critical
I feel like he has watched
a lot of anime, right?
And he does definitely-
- I think he actually
watches more anime than me.
- I think he does as well.
But I don't know like you look
at Critical and you're like,
"You're not a weeb, you know what I mean?
You're just a normal anime fan."
- Felix was like that too.
Like at one point he was doing
a bunch of like anime reviews
and he was doing a lot of videos on anime
and I'm just like, "Okay,
I can tell you like anime,
but obviously your entire
life is not anime."
- Right, and I think that's why people
really liked his review, 'cause
it felt like a very honest-
- It was like a new
perspective of opinions
on certain shows.
- Because I feel like when
maybe you're an anime YouTuber,
when you're reviewing an anime, it's like,
"I'm reviewing it because it's anime."
Whereas I feel like, if Critical,
or any other person makes review,
who doesn't talk about anime content.
It feels like they have something to say
because they've gone out of
their way to make a video
about something normally
wouldn't make a video about,
to talk about it.
Whereas, you know,
Garnt talking about Attack
on Titan season four,
of course, Garnt is gonna
talk about the att...
You know what I mean?
Like it's expected and it's like-
- 'Cause he wants those views.
- Yeah, but obviously I mean,
but if someone else does
it, right, it's like,
"Oh, they must really like, be passionate
about what they're trying to convey here."
And I think that's really refreshing.
And it's something that,
I mean, maybe this is,
again this could be from
being an issue in myself.
And I can understand the thought process
of why they're talking
about it, but I don't know,
I guess and that's why I
think I've distanced myself
from anime in some aspects, like-
- And it's like not to
undermine the passion
of actual anime fans, right?
Like, you know, I'm sure there's-
- I still fucking love the cultured anime.
- I'm sure there's a massive amount
of like hardcore anime fans
who will make Attack on Titan videos
because they genuinely love the show.
- Oh, of course, yeah, sorry.
I'm not trying to say that everyone-
- Yeah, of course, but like...
No, I get what you're saying, it's like,
when you do see that anime
review from someone who
you don't expects an anime
review from, it's just like,
"Oh, okay."
- 'Cause like, looking
on the internet now,
there's like so many low key
anime fans that, you know-
- They just like suddenly
coming out of the woodwork.
It's like, I've always been an anime fan.
- Yeah, it's like sometimes
you see these little hints
every now and again,
where it's like this
completely normal YouTuber
that you don't expect to
watch anime and like make
a very subtle anime reference.
And you're just like,
wait, are you a weeb?
Did you have something to say?
- That's why I always get
like scared and surprised
when a YouTuber who I thought
had nothing to do with anime
like follows me on Twitter.
I'm like, "Something's up,
do perhaps like anime?"
- Or maybe they've just seen like,
"Wow, this guy likes a
lot of porn that I like,
maybe I should follow him back."
(both chuckling)
- Damn.
- 'Cause I remember I was
watching like one of the latest
Internet Historian videos
like a few weeks ago
and then like, you know,
it was a very normal
Internet historian video
then right at the end,
he was like giving some shout outs to like
his other social medias.
And then he mentioned like
streaming and everything.
And then he showed her a clip
of Corona and I'm just like,
"Where did this come from?"
- Are you serious?
- Yeah, he did, (chuckling)
its like right at the end as well.
So it's at the point where
most people click off.
- Good tastes, good tastes.
- I'm like, "Are you a
cultured individual too?"
- Would you like to come on to the podcast
and talk about the goddess that is Corona?
- Oh, my God, (chuckling) Jesus.
- 'Cause I'd be down.
Yeah, but yeah, I don't know.
It's just fascinating to watch, especially
I'd say in like the last two, three years
of just all these people
just suddenly coming out,
you know saying-
- How'd you feel about anime
being like way more normalized?
- How do I feel about going mainstream?
- Yeah, normalized, I was trying
to think of the right word.
'Cause it isn't mainstream yet?
- I mean, that's the eternal debate.
It's like, is it truly mainstream yet?
- I don't think so.
- It depends on your definition
of mainstream, right?
- I mean, it's not like
everyone's talking about 24/7
but is everyone, you know?
- I mean, people argued
that like, you know,
"All "Demon Slayer" was
trending on Twitter, right?
It must've gone mainstream."
- And I'm like, I don't
think it's mainstream yet.
I think it's like about
three, four years away
from like properly being
mainstream, I'd say.
- I don't know, I feel like
every time there's a big show
it helps a lot.
- Its certainly on it's way.
- I mean, Attack on Titan season four
will hopefully help a
lot in terms of like,
"Hey, here's a completed
masterpiece," hopefully.
- I mean the amount of
money that the fucking
"Demon Slayer" movie
made in like the first,
like two weeks of it coming out.
- Yeah, it's still like dwarf
numbers compared to like-
- Proper-
- The giant "Blockbuster"
four to $5 million
in the first week, which is amazing, but-
- Yeah.
- I mean like, fuck it,
"Avengers" got like a billion
in like the first week of us,
which is obviously like perish-
- But then again if I had
Robert Downey Jr's voice
in "Demon Slayer" it
would probably get more.
- And again, it is Japan
so it's kind of a very isolated market.
So it's kind of hard to say
like how well it would do.
- That's why I'd say that
it's still like a few years
from being like properly mainstream.
But at this point it's
not like anime itself
isn't mainstream, but at least pretty much
everyone knows what anime is now.
- It's accepted world wide.
- Yeah, there's never this
debate of, you mentioned an anime
and people were like, "What the fuck?
What language are you speaking?"
- What is an anime?
- It's weird because
I think that you know,
there's 40, 50 year olds
online who talked to
who get all the anime
references and keep up with it.
But then I've got 25 year
old friends in the UK
who are like, "What's that?"
Like what's a dark note?
What's that like?
(both chuckling)
- What's a dark note.
- No, legit, like so it's,
I think we almost get
all like perceptions, especially us,
it's because we are surrounded
by like-minded individuals
to an extend, we're
surrounded by people online.
We never interact with
people really outside
of the online bubble, even
when we leave our house,
we are normally going to an
event with other online people,
people who work in the
same industry, right?
But when I go back to the
UK or I go back to Wales
and I talked to my friends,
they literally have like,
no fucking clue about any anime.
Maybe there'll be like,
"What's that one punch man?"
Or something, you know?
- But the fact that
they've heard about that,
is fucking massive.
- They might but they are my age,
I would expect them to be
like, "Come on, you are 24,
you should know what
date note is, come on.
- Yeah, I mean like with titles like that,
as long as you're on the internet,
it's pretty hard to avoid, right?
- Yeah, like it's weird.
'Cause like when you go into
those kinds of social circles
and you realize,
"Oh," you don't spend
all your time on Twitter
and seeing all that fucking drama
and everything happening on online,
you're just watching fucking
"Love Island" or whatever.
And just-
(both chuckling)
- I fucking hate reality TV.
- That's like a whole new world.
But even some people that I know who,
don't spend any time on the internet
and everything like that,
still I've heard of some
of these like bigger shows
and to me that is still a massive step
than what it was even like five years ago.
And like going back 10 year-
- Because you had to
like seek out that shit.
- The reason I started
YouTube is to make friends
who I could speak to about it.
And now I don't really
want to speak about it.
(all laughing)
I mean I do, I just-
- Fuck these friends.
- I mean, again, going back
to the podcast, it's like
I did wanna speak about
it but I didn't wanna
make a whole podcast talking about it.
I wanna make a podcast
and talk shit about it.
- I mean, I think the only
reason why we labeled ourselves
in anime podcast is because
all three of us individually
are already established in that field.
- I guess it was like a comfort thing.
But then when we got in the flow of it
I think we realized that
like, I think us just chatting
is like-
- Yeah, 'cause I remember
like when we first were
conceptualizing this podcast we were like,
"All right, let's just like,
maybe like the first like
10 or 20 episodes, we
should like solely focus
on the stuff that people know us for.
And then maybe every
now and then, you know-
- The whole time I'm like,
I might not want to do this.
- So we'll slide IN some other stuff.
And then, you know
episode one rolls around,
we don't mention anime a single time.
I think we only talked
about attack one time
for like 20 minutes on the first episode.
- I've watched a lot of animated podcasts.
You know what I mean?
I've watched-
- What do you think about them?
- Okay, well this is the thing, right?
There's only so much
you can say about anime.
And like, I feel like a lot
of the times it's like three
or four people who
regurgitate the same point
with slightly different
wording back to each other.
They're like, "Hmm, yes. I agree."
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And it's like, "Okay, cool."
I mean, some people, some
people are looking for that.
But to me it's like not exciting
anymore, I don't know why.
- Because there's so much of it out there.
- There's too much
anime, and by the time...
I've gotten to the point now where
I don't really have as
much time as I'd like
to do everything that I wanna do.
So now I just wait
until the season's over.
And I'm like, right, so
it was the best show guys.
What was the show that was-
- 'Cause I feel like
out of the three of us,
I've probably watch the most anime.
- Yeah you do, I'm the most
normal hee everyone knows that.
- Yeah, and we've got like a spectrum here
where Joey's like, "I don't
even watch anime anymore.
I just read manga."
(chuckling)
You know they call The Anime Man.
- He's The Anime Man who
reads more manga like anyone.
- I feel like 2020 has been the year
where I have watched the
least amounts of anime,
like in probably like last five years
and that's partly due
to the fact that I feel
like 2020 has just been a
really weak year for anime.
- It has yeah.
- Like some variants
know the faults of like
the anime itself, it's just
the weld situation right now
where it's just less shows being made.
So it's just, it's been really weird
because I've been watching this anime
I've had to find my enjoyment
for like other things,
like Vtubers and gacha games.
And it's really like broadened my horizons
to like other kind of anime
subcultures and everything
and like the weeb subculture
and everything like that.
- The Otaku just overall or Otaku cultures
like really just expanding,
I think just in general with
the success of, you know,
the as you mentioned like the Vtubers
and gacha games and all that shit.
And it's just, I don't know,
it's really interesting to
watch especially as someone
who's been in that realm
for most of my life.
- Yeah.
- Do you find consuming
media in 2020 to be a bit
worse in general?
Just due to the climate of
everything going on right now?
- I mean, I find that
consuming media periods
has become worse in general, I don't know.
- Because you kind of-
- Because of 2020, or just in general?
- Just in general.
I feel like there's
just too much media now.
- I think it has to do
mostly with the environment
that we're like placed in.
It's like for a lot of
people consuming media
is really the only
thing we can do to like-
- I think that's almost like
a little bit about it as well
is that 2020s has just been so...
I mean, everyone can
relate to this, right?
It's been, shit, right?
- Unless you are from the
future and you're watching this,
2020 was a shit year.
- It's been kind of shit.
Every time like I have free time to do it.
I'm like, "Oh, this is free time,
I could've been doing something fun
and doing something with my life,
but I'm stuck here watching this anime.
I've got nothing better to do."
And it's kind of sad, it doesn't feel like
I'm really choosing to
do it, it feels like
I'm doing it out of like, just like-
- Yeah.
- Like I got nothing better to do.
And I, you know, what worries me,
I can't enjoy anime, right?
Who fucking cares, but
at the end of the day,
I'm just trying to explain
why I guess my enjoyment
right now of like anime, especially
it's probably been the thing
that's dropped off most.
- I've definitely like, I
hate to admit it to myself
but I've definitely had a
massive fucking burn out
with anime, like-
- Yeah.
- Just not only because
like this year's anime
has been kind of mid but
also just the fact that,
yeah, I don't know, I've
just been doing this shit
for so long now where it's like-
- You know, I made a video
like, like six months
into my YouTube career,
like five years ago now.
Like why I don't watch much anime anymore.
(both laughing)
And I made a video, I think
it's actually still up
and in that video, I'm just kind of like,
"Yeah, like, I don't know, it's weird.
I just started making YouTube videos
and I just don't watch
much anime anymore."
I kind of watch like two
or three a season at most.
And then I realized,
like I thought that
would go back to normal,
never did go back to normal.
I've just been at that
same stage the whole time.
- I feel like that's just the normal cycle
of a fucking anime fun.
- Yeah, what I realized is like
when you first get into
anime or you have that period
when you start watching
a fuck ton of anime
I thought it would be like, okay well-
- You thought that will last forever?
- Well, I thought that, okay,
when that honeymoon period
if you will end it, I thought,
"Well, you know maybe next summer
when I have a lot of free time
it'll come back round."
I told myself that like
every year it just never has.
And I realized, oh, this is
just like the new normal.
- And then when you wake up
first day of the summer break
and you are like, I have nothing to do.
(both laughing)
- I feel like it was a real tough for me.
This year especially
when I always felt like
I was behind on anime.
Well, like I don't have
enough time to keep up
with everything I wanted.
And then in the one year
where you have the most
free time to do whatever
you want it's just like
watching anime just felt
like a chore at points
because you're just like
I'm not taking a break
from something else.
I just feel like I'm doing this
'cause I have nothing else to do.
- If you start making
excuses, like, you know
when you were back at school
and you had to study, right.
It's like, "oh, I have
to like clean my room."
- Yeah.
- I have to go shopping.
- This is hosting existential
episode of the podcast.
What are we here for anyway?
What are we doing?
- Are we truly an anime podcast?
- Why do we watch anime?
- For fun?
Yeah, I don't know, like-
- Okay, by the time when we were...
This will be out, the
drifting episode will be out.
And then, you know, the,
the Calli episode to be out
and then we're filming another thing,
that's coming out soon.
- Second special of the year.
- I know we spent listen
to YouTube burnout,
but I feel like a lot of my
energy that was once anime
and consuming content has just been pushed
in different avenues,
and I feel like that's-
- All my energy has been
pushed into Trash Tastes.
- And the game we spoke about that
I don't like talking about
topics I spoke about,
but it's like,
I guess I wanted to talk
about this topic in general,
just because I know that
we get a lot of comments
being like, "Why don't we
talk about anime any more?"
But then there's those
people on the other side of-
- I feel like it's 50, 50.
- Yeah, there's some people who are like,
"I fucking hate it when
they talk about anime."
Like I wonder to the
viewers, do you prefer
when we speak about anime or not?
I mean, we're gonna
speak about it regardless
when we want to, but it's
nice to hear your opinion.
- Yeah, we wanna hear your opinions,
but at the end of the day
we're gonna talk about
whatever the fucking we wanna talk about.
(both laughing)
But like, you know, but
that to me is just like
reassuring that we have
an audience that...
Because I always thought, "Oh
yeah like 99.9% of the people
who are subscribed to
and watch Trash Taste
are only there because they like anime.
- Yeah, I mean, I thought
when we started the podcast,
I knew it was gonna be a risk, being like,
let's just talk about ourselves.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Let's just fucking talk
about life, you know?
- Because there's someone
who's pigeon holed themselves
into that side of things-
- You never really spoke
about yourself publicly.
And I just wanted to 'cause I'm like,
"Man, I flipped people-"
- 'Cause I love myself.
(both chuckling)
- I just feel like I'm a gift.
(all chuckling)
I mean, 'cause on your chat
I really thought that as a YouTuber
that it was like this image
that people had of me.
And I really just wanted
to like talk about myself
and help or not help.
Just like, I dunno have
this image of the people...
The image people had of
me breath more truth,
so when they watch my videos, you know
they might see me behaving a certain way
but when they're go and watch Trash Taste,
they know what I'm really
like when I'm on the show.
Right? They know that it's-
- I mean, that's why I like
to preface it by saying like
on Trash Taste, we're not
The Anime Man, Guk and CDwag.
We are Joey, Garnt and Connor.
- Yeah.
- Because I like to think
that how you guys see us
on this show is the closest to reality
of how we actually are.
Whereas like, you know,
on our main channels,
of course like any good main channel,
there's a performative side to it, right?
Where it's like, we're acting
as like that character.
- In my content on my main channel is like
way different from anything
we do on Trash Taste.
And that's why like working on
some of the more ambitious
projects on Trash Taste
has been like a breath of fresh air to me.
'Cause it's just something different.
- [Connor] Like the drifting video
was just a challenge all around.
I mean, that was like-
- I mean, that was a challenge
on every fucking end.
I mean, we briefly talked
about like how much effort
we put in that video but Holy hell,
I learned so much from
just doing the episode
and just seeing all the little things
you don't think about until
the day of the shoot, right?
- By the way, go check
it out if you haven't,
link in the description.
- I mean, I already want to make more,
but also want some more help.
'Cause like, I feel like being
in charge of all the tech
is so boring it's like,
what is Joey's might work,
and this is kinda work-
- We need to start hiring like staff.
- We need a P.A.
People living in Japan.
(all laughing)
- We're hiring.
- But what are we saying, fuck it!
- About like the, is Trash
Tastes an anime podcast or not?
- Right.
- So, we're just talking
about the evolution
of the anime community in the past years
and how how like Poplar has gotten, like,
here's the question, where do
you see the anime community
and the anime fandom in
like the next few years?
- It's really hard to say because I mean-
- Honestly, same.
I think it'll be the same age.
- You think it will be the same?
- Roughly.
- I think it would be the same
but definitely we're
gonna start to see more
as you put it, weebs than
actual like anime fans, right?
Because I feel that the
whole genre of anime fans
is kind of like, I don't
wanna say it's dying,
but it's slowly becoming not as like
in the spotlight as was before-
- Like saying you are an anime
fan is sounding more and more
like you're just saying you're a gamer.
(Joey chuckling)
It just means nothing,
'cause everyone's gam...
You know what I mean?
- I mean, I remember when
I used to play online games
like League of Legends
and I would make like a
weeb joke or whatever,
and then like people would be like,
"you're a fucking weed, you disgust us."
(Garnt chuckling)
But now it would be like
one person in the lobby
who doesn't know the reference.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- I mean, I genuinely don't
think that much would change.
- Soon we're gonna be starting...
We're gonna be calling
ourselves Otaku goals
instead of gamer goals, right?
(both chuckling)
Yeah, I'm an Otaku.
- I wonder, do you ever think that maybe
like the degenerate side
of anime might hold it back
from going more mainstream?
- No, I feel like that subculture
is always gonna be there because-
- If anything it's grown.
- Yeah, 'cause right now
it's like people were scared
that anime becoming mainstream would make
this degenerate side of anime,
like kind of calmed down a bit.
But if anything, just because
there's so much more anime
being made nowadays, you
don't really have to pick-
- Who the fuck thinks
that it would calm down
the degenerative side?
- I mean, I've seen comments online too-
- I think the general stigma is that.
- Oh my God.
- As someone who is in
this degenerate side.
- You've seen how much Pokemon porn
there is that shit?
That stuff doesn't chill
out with more people.
- As someone on the degenerative side,
like seeing all these new
faces coming into these,
just so wholesome, like
just pure hearted people
coming into it, being
like, "What is hint eye?"
and I'm just like, "Let me show you."
- Let me open your world.
- Yeah, I'm like the joker
and the guys are like,
I love seeing people suffer through this,
and just realizing that the
world that they're living in
is actually burning from the inside.
It's like-
- Joey just wants to see the world burn.
- I love seeing the world burn.
- Alrighty then.
- Just be like let me
teach you a little thing
about Dogan codes, okay.
- Yeah, but I feel like it,
because the the big change I've seen
is not in the content of
anime that's being made
but just the sheer amounts
of anime that's being made.
It's like this season
we have like 38 shows
there in the season.
- I just couldn't give a fuck.
- Which is like, if you try
to keep up with everything
that's watching three seasons of anime
in one fucking week who the is doing this?
You know what I mean.
- Because 20 years ago,
I think I remember this
from a video I made
I think 20 years ago
in like early 2000's each
season, we had seven shows.
- Wow.
- Which is much more manageable.
- Yeah, there was a period
like 10 to 20 years ago
where you could you could
legitimately follow everything
that was going on in the season and be up,
be kept up with like the conversation
with what was coming out
because there wasn't that much to watch.
And now it's just, okay, what
kind of anime fan are you?
Do you like the mainstream
shown and stuff?
Do you like, you know,
degenerate stuff, idol stuff?
Whatever or like a mixture
of everything like that.
You could pick and choose whatever mood
you're in the mood to watch.
- There's an enemy for every
niche and every fetish now.
- And the thing is like, I
feel like the quality of anime
in general has gotten a little better
because everything like...
I feel like everything's just good.
- You've got to stand out now.
- Yeah, exactly.
- And it's like TV,
like TV is so good now.
- Yeah.
- Their is so many good TV shows
that like every week
you're getting recommended
like a 9.5 out of 10.
You're like, "Oh fuck yeah,
I mean, I barely finished
"House of Cards" and then
look what happened to-
- But like the problem
with that is it's like
the biggest first world
problem in the world,
when everything's good-
(chuckling)
- Everything's too good.
- When everything's good
nothing stands out anymore.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- Sometimes I watch a seasonal anime now
and it's like, this is
the biggest seven to eight
out of 10 in a season
anime and I just forget it.
And I compare these like
what I would call now,
average shows, and I
compare it to some of like
the kind of like the mid
shows that I would watch
back when I was getting into anime.
And they are like way better,
but for some reason I like...
I remember watching like a show like,
I'm going off the top of my head.
Maybe something like "Darker than Black"
which is also I fucking enjoyed that show,
but it's like I think back and I'm like,
if that show had aired in our days
it would just wouldn't stand out at all.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I kinda love that show.
- That's the thing though right?
It's like normally in an out of 10 rating,
five is the average and
it really says something
when nowadays seven or
eight is the average.
- This episode is
sponsored by Skill Share.
Conner to you.
- I did not expect that, okay.
This holiday season give
the gift that means more,
get creative and learn how to
make the perfect handmade gift
with Skill Shares Online classes.
- [Joey] Skillshare is an
online learning community
that offers membership with meaning
with so much to explore
real projects to create,
and the support of fellow creatives
Skill Share empowers you
to accomplish real growth.
- We've all been learning
how to read script
and it's going great,
list multiple topics.
If you watch a podcast,
you might be interested
in video editing or Photoshop
or any of that stuff
that goes into making YouTube content.
And I guarantee no matter
what skill you want to learn
there is a class for it on Skill Share.
- If you love the way we sound.
There's also an audio production lessons
that are available as well.
- What's Joey doing with his head?
(both chuckling)
- I'm agreeing.
- I have to get up my phone,
but I've actually used,
quite a while back when
I did promote Skill Share
on my own channel,
I did do the Adobe Photoshop
CC essentials training course
because I sucked at Photoshop.
And this was a great way to
get very condensed guides
on how to do certain things in Photoshop
that I still use to this
day, thanks to Skill Share.
- This holiday season give
a gift that means more
get creative, I was very,
very aggressive there
because I am so passionate
about how to get creative
and learning how to make
the perfect handmade gift.
- I'm scared.
- I'm worried.
When you put time, effort
and creativity into a gift,
it shows how much you care.
(both laughing)
- Give a gift that's one of a kind,
completely personalized
or perfectly imperfect.
Damn that's deeper.
- Skill Share is also
incredibly affordable
especially when compared to the price
of in-person classes and workshops,
an annual subscription
is less than $10 a month.
- Are you saying that if I
pay less than $10 a month,
I can get every knowledge.
- You can get the
knowledge of the internet.
- Damn, everything I've ever wanted.
- Unlock your brain for
less than $10 a month.
- So explore your creativity
at skillshare.coms/trashtastes
and get a free trial of
a premium membership.
- That is skillshare.com/trashtaste
for a free trial
of premium membership.
- Thank you Skill Share for sponsoring.
Back to the episode.
- Just going off from
what I was saying before,
where I feel like it's just
harder to consume media now
because just less things stand out.
And there's so much
choice that sometimes...
You ever got to have a
point where you sit down,
you have like your lunch or something.
And you're like, "Oh, let's
put something on a lunch."
And then you spend like
15 minutes scrolling down
your anime list of you
have Netflix or something.
And then you are not finishing your lunch
by the time you like
finished scrolling down
and looking at everything?
- Yeah, (chuckling) yeah.
- I just clicked the first thing
into my YouTube recommended
that's half decent.
- Really.
- Yeah, 'cause I'm like,
if I know I'm gonna be eating
I can put Netflix on, 'cause
I know I'm gonna eat the food
with before the credits
even fucking finish.
- Yeah, I always have to put on YouTube,
but for me, it's the opposite,
I put on a video that where I'm like,
Okay, yeah I can rewatch that.
- Right.
- It's usually a video
that I know I enjoyed.
And I know I liked, but
has the re-playability
that I can watch it again during lunch.
So weirdly enough, I don't actually go out
and like look for new videos
during like a lunch break or something.
- Yeah.
- Like, I need to be like in that mood
of like discovery, right?
Just what it sounds-
- Before I go to bed, the amount
of times I've open Netflix
and had luck and just be like
"All of these seem like
I'd probably have fun,
but fuck, I mean, I don't know.
I guess I'll put report of the week on,
and watch it on a fucking-
(both chuckling)
I dunno, like-
- Yeah, exactly.
- Here is a question
for you though Conner,
you said you watch way less
anime now than you used to.
Would you say that maybe you
might be growing out of it
in any sense of the world.
(Joey gasping)
Like it just doesn't fit
your lifestyle anymore?
- You maturing out of anime?
- Yeah, no, I mean, I still love anime.
And like a bang of shows,
but I think I've just
I don't know, stop
fucking lying to myself.
(Garnt chuckling)
Like I think because of
the position I was in.
I felt indebted to animate
like I had to watch it,
you know, back when I
first started I was like,
"It's an anime, you
should have to watch it,
to keep up with it, you know?"
So I can be like, I can
keep up with the hot takes.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But I think, you know, maybe
like two, three years ago
I just kind of realized like,
I don't like doing this.
I'm just gonna watch the
biggest shows that come out
and enjoy them and have a great time.
- [Garnt] Yeah, right.
- I love anime, like the way I can show-
- But you don't care to like go out
and like discover the show is good or not?
- No, I have no ambition to do that.
I'll just wait until everyone
agrees a show is good,
I'll watch it, 'cause I'd know
the show is gonna be good.
I've had so many experiences
where I've just watched an
animated that's so fucking boring
that I'm like, "Okay, I mean, yeah.
I guess "Decadence" was fine, you know.
- Did you watch "Decadence"?
- I watched like three
episodes of "Decadence"
'cause everyone was hyping it up.
- Yeah, everyone was hyping it up is good.
(Connor sighing)
(Joey chuckling)
- I totally agree with him, yeah.
- There is so many shows nowadays,
which is seasonal anime and I feel like
people only hype it up
because it's a seasonal anime
and nothing else to talk about.
So someone's got to hype up something.
- And it's really telling
because 90% of those shows
like get hyped up while its airing,
you don't hear about after it's finished.
- I also just watch a lot more YouTube,
like I think on average
I watch like 40 hours a week on YouTube.
- Yeah, I agree, I've
watched a lot more YouTube.
- But it's a lot of YouTube.
The thing is right,
okay, YouTube tells me,
'cause you can actually look on the app
and it can actually tell you how much
you should watch week.
And it'll tell you how much
you watch on average day.
It wasn't like four hours
a day I watch or something
on average least.
But like, I mean, like I said, 47-
- I'm probably the same.
I just haven't checked.
- The problem is right? It's not-
- It's only the YouTube app?
- Yeah, its only YouTube app.
- Ill check right now.
- Its like deep in the settings.
- Oh no.
- So I mean, I'll look
while I'm explaining it,
but I remember that their was a...
Because essentially right
when I go to the gym
for two hours, cause I
have YouTube premium,
so you can, you can lock your
phone and listen to audio.
I'll watch YouTube videos
or just audio only.
So that's like two hours.
While I take a shit,
you bet I'm putting the YouTube
video on for two minutes.
When I'm brushing my teeth,
YouTube video, while I'm
in the bath, YouTube video,
when I'm working and it's not important,
I don't need to listen, YouTube video.
- Yeah, I have four
and a half hours daily.
- See, did you think you can
watch four hours YouTube?
- No, I've apparently already just today
watched three hours.
- I mean, I know that I watch
hell of a lot of YouTube-
- Garnt doesn't wanna know.
- If I don't look, I don't have to know.
(both laughing)
- Dude, on Sunday, I watched
eight hours of YouTube.
- Jesus.
- I don't even remember doing that.
- No, because here's the thing why like-
- I've watched a 50
hours in the last week.
- Yeah, because here's
the thing about YouTube
is that it's just content on YouTube
is just that much easier
to consume, right?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you know, when you have...
Do you have kind of like a
subconscious value system
when it comes to like content.
So when you watch like a
Netflix show or something,
it's like you're sitting down
and you're paying the
fuck attention, right?
- Yeah.
- But when it's a YouTube video
you could be doing whatever
and you just can have it
on the in the background
and just not really give
a shit about it, you know?
- Yeah, I also like keeping
up with YouTube a lot.
Like I think I'm way more
invested in like YouTube,
like as a-
- As a subculture?
- Yeah, than anime, honestly,
like I've been following
YouTube like religiously
for like seven years.
So I know all like the drama,
everything that's ever
happened on YouTube.
I'm sure, like if we did a
quiz, I'm sure A stack wise-
- Are you are YouTube fan?
- I'm a big YouTube fan.
- I know exactly what you mean.
'Cause it's exactly the same
in like every subculture
of YouTube as well, 'cause
like I know a lot Anitubers
who I swear spend most
of their time watching
other Anitubers as
opposed to watching anime.
And I feel like every Anituber
has been through that stage
where you find yourself
watching more Anitubes
than you do watching anime.
- Yeah, it's like, I
could watch this anime
or I could watch this Anitubers
talking about that anime.
- Exactly, and now it's just growing
from I watch other Anitubers
I just watch other YouTuber channels.
- In general, yeah.
- Rather than like my anime consumption
has remained the same this entire time.
But my consumption of like
watching other anime YouTubers
and watching other YouTubers
has just grown immensely.
- Yeah.
- And that's why I feel like it's so weird
whenever I see the comments
and you know the comment I'm
talking about where it's like,
"Oh, I'm having trouble
keeping up with anime
but a two hour Trash Tastes episode.
(Joey chuckling)
Give me that shit any day of the weekend,
you know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- I guess because it's
easy to digest, right?
I think with anime,
I mean Joey can relate to that you know,
the subtitles I can't
fucking focus you know,
it's like, all right, okay fine,
I guess I'll pay attention.
- Well, I mean, I have to
focus on listening, right?
- That's true.
- But I still, yeah...I mean-
- I don't know, I just it's sad.
'Cause I just don't wanna admit
that I've fallen out of anime really,
I think that's the saddest part.
- Right, especially because
you've like followed it
for all this time, right?
- Yeah, I guess it's kind of sad being...
I guess I'm just not into
anime as much as I used to be.
Like, I don't know.
- Do you think that's because-
- Part of growing up.
- Do you think as well
that it might have to do
with the fact that you have grown up
or is it the fact of like just the quality
of the shows or like the
type of show coming out?
- I mean, we got better
anime now, let's be honest.
The anime is better now than it was.
- But did you feel like maybe it's just,
you enjoy different kinds of media now.
'Cause, let's remove
anime from the equation
but what's like the last TV
show you properly enjoyed,
anime or not?
- Uh, "Great Pretender" I guess
- Okay.
- And that was like, that's an anime,
and I was like two, three months ago.
- Yeah, right.
- What the fuck I've I been watching?
(all laughing)
- YouTube apparently.
'Cause, here's what
I've realized, you know,
when I find a show that I really enjoy,
it's so rare nowadays because
we consume so much media,
but so much of it is
just fucking forgettable.
And that's why you like,
you do watch a lot of YouTube, right?
But is that the same kind
of enjoyment that you get
from watching some of your favorite shows
that you remember from, you know, as a kid
or when you're marathoning has shown
you just really, really into it.
And I feel like just because
we can see more media
doesn't necessarily mean
that we value media the same
you know, it's just, I feel like
we've just programmed our
brain to never have dead space
so we're always consuming something.
- And I guess 'cause of
the age of the internet
and you know, being more
knowledgeable about anime
especially in opposition, right?
It's almost commodified, so-
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I guess it's kind of
weird, 'cause it's...
I think my motivation for
wanting to watch anime now
to just feel in the loop.
- [Garnt] Right.
- Not because I actually
want to watch that show.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Which is why I've just
fully admitted to myself.
I'm just only going to watch the big shows
that everyone agrees with.
- But that's the thing, right?
It's like, it definitely doesn't help
when everyone else around you is like,
"Hey, have you watched this show?
Have you watched this show?
Have you watched this?
Or what are your thoughts on this show?"
- Because to us it's different now
because it was just like
anime has become a job
and someone who watches
as much anime as me,
like I can see a show and I can be like,
"I can see that this is a good show."
You know what I mean?
Like I can break it down to be like,
"Yeah, I know why I know
why this is a good show.
I know why people are hyping this up."
But when you reached a
point where you kind of
become part of the seasonal cycle,
you kind of see the patterns.
There's always these, the same-
- You are turning it into
a fucking conveyor belt.
- I had that exact experience
when I went to go watch
"The Damon Slayer" movie, I was like
I took one look at the
poster and I was like
I know exactly what's
gonna happen in this movie.
- Yeah, exactly, right?
- Like just from like,
"Oh yeah, this character
is gonna do this and this
character is gonna do this."
And sure enough, I was like
90% correct on what happened.
- Yeah.
- And like, is that a good thing?
Or is it, I mean, I still
enjoyed it, but it's, you know
The whole like wow factor
was completely gone, right?
And I think that's the entire reason why
I've kind of been burned out on anime
and I've been much more into manga
because like nowadays, especially nowadays
everybody is talking about
every anime that matters.
- Yeah.
- It's almost like an escape pool.
- But the manga side of things
because like 90% of manga
don't have translations,
it's still a mystery.
- Yeah.
- It's what the anime community was
10 years ago.
- Like 10 years ago.
I totally agree and that's why like,
I love going into the world of manga,
'cause in anime you don't get that feeling
of discovering that hidden gem any more.
There's no feeling of discovery
because everyone knows
where everything good is.
- You know what's gonna
come out three seasons.
- There's no surprise anymore.
- Yeah.
- Like even when there's a good show
that I can recommend
someone watching the season
to me I'm just like, I can
tell this is a good show
and I can tell people would enjoy it.
- Yeah.
- But I don't enjoy it in
the same kind of like, wow
this is something new to me.
I'm like, "Okay, this is just
a very solid show this season
and I recommend people watch
it if they wanna experience
X kind of thing."
But when I go into manga, I'm just like,
"I don't know, what's gonna be good.
I'd know what's gonna be bad."
- The amount of times
I've like finished reading
a manga series and I've said to myself,
"How was no one talking about this?"
Is way more than any amount of
anime that I've ever covered.
Because again, like that whole mystery of-
- It's an event as well,
like, you know, it's
coming out the season.
It's one of the things you're
watching weekly, right?
Like, manga is so ongoing
that it's hard to,
I think, have that kind of hype for it.
- Right.
- I feel like there's way more
choice with manga as well.
And it's such a vast world that-
- That fucking love it.
- I don't feel like anyone's gonna be able
to read everything, so-
- Challenge accepted.
(both chuckling)
- Actually, yeah.
Like you said, first-world
problem is the podcast.
(both chuckling)
My toilet seat temperature
is one Celsius, off my luck,
what can I say?
- I'm dead, I'm dead.
- No, I mean, it's totally is,
I feel like a problem that has come
with this new generation
where there's just
so much to do so much to
watch, it's impossible-
- There's too much to do.
- It's like that whole fucking
meme of like, you know,
white people rewatch in the office
for like the 10th time, it is just like,
that's funny, I'll laugh-
(all chuckling)
- I've rewatched " Always
Sunny in Philadelphia"
more times than I can fucking count.
- Its funny basically, like-
(all laughing)
- Actually though.
- I liked that.
- All right now.
(all laughing)
- But I feel like, because there's so much
we've desensitized ourselves
to so much as well.
And like, you know, I
look at someone like you
who probably watches
more content, more media
than you ever have in your life.
But thinking back about
what's actually memorable
its like hard, right?
- I like...
You, I think you were
like, "What the fuck?"
Like when I play League
of Legends or play games
I watch YouTube videos
on the other like screen.
- Yeah, I can't do that.
- You can't?
- It's the same as
people who can, you know
watch a TV show while reading a book,
it's like, how do you do that?
- That's fucked up.
- Yeah, right. It's
like, how do you do that?
Or like listening to music
while reading a book.
I can't even do that.
- I can do that.
- I can't do it.
- Okay, here's the question.
Do you remember the first time
you watched a YouTube video
at 1.5 or two times speed?
- No, I've never done it.
- Have you ever done that?
- Of course, yeah.
- I've never done that.
- And I realized, I...
'Cause I realized why
would I ever want this?
That just means I'm not
enjoying the content
how it's supposed to be like enjoyed.
And then I realized,
"Wait, I could just consume this content
in a faster, in like a
shorter time period."
And then-
- There are people who
legitly watch every video.
- And then I realized it was like a habit
like that was subconsciously
forming and then realize,
"Wait, I'm not even fucking
enjoying this content anymore.
Literally, I'm just watching
it just to keep up."
And I'm like, "That's pretty fast."
'Cause that's kind of like hacking my mind
into what entertainment
is at the end of the day.
You know what I mean?
- I do think time-
- It's slowly turning
into like an info Wars.
(all laughing)
What is entertainment?
Are we consuming too much media?
- I do think times too
should be reserved for
shitty tutorials that
take too fucking long.
(all chuckling)
too long to explain.
- I totally agree with you.
- I don't trust anyone
who opens up a tutorial
and doesn't immediately
skip to two minutes in.
Like there's so many fucking
channels that are like...
Tutorial is like, "Yoh, what's up guys?"
and like, you should not...
Tutorials should not be
allowed to do intros.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- You should basically just tell me what-
- Just give me the information.
- Yeah, just fucking,
get right into it, dude.
Like "hey, what's up guys
I'm uploading daily content.
Okay, next week I'm live streaming.
I'm gonna be talking about."
- I remember the other day
'cause I was trying to like
fix something with my cam link, right?
And I was like, "Okay,
I need to figure out
some issues with my cam link."
And there was this video,
which was like, you know,
five issues with cam
link and how to fix it.
It was like a 10 minute video.
I'm like, All right,
like maybe it's like
two minutes each, right?
- It doesn't need to be 10 minutes.
- And I'm like, dude, this dude like legit
I swear to God for the first six minutes.
He was just plugging all the shit,
and like trying to add
like jokes and stuff.
And he's like,
"All right, let's get into
the meat of the video."
And I'm like, "There's
only four minutes left."
How are you gonna talk about five problems
and how to solve them in four minutes?
- Oh my God, dude.
- You know, it's a big
issue, when even like...
'Cause you can Google this stuff
and Google will show
you the video results.
And it'll literally skip to the point
where it thinks tutorial actually starts.
(all laughing)
Which is like, if Google
is automating this
why do people think that anyone else
is gonna fucking watch it?
- I remember like 2010 when
it was like video game,
like, "Oh, where's this thing
or how to do this thing."
Always watch a video, the
video will show you exactly
how to do it and we'll jump right into it.
But now it's kind of like-
- No commentary.
- Now it's going backwards where I'm like,
"I guess I'll click the forum first
and see if I can get the
information in 10 seconds."
- Yeah.
- So I'm gonna click on this
20 minute video and fuck,
I see the same operating system.
- Yeah, it's like,
"I don't care about your
cam link jokes, all right,
just tell me how to fix my
fucking cam link, please."
- I can give all the times
that I've had like a tech issue
and it's some guy with
like the thickest accent
like trying to explain them like,
okay, fuck, what is he saying?
Times two?"
- And he's like literally
swallowing the microphone as well.
So like, even at times
two-speed it's like, "I can't."
And you have to go down
to the comments to see
if someone's like
paraphrase it in some way.
- You know what I hate?
YouTube has started doing
a thing where you can...
I mean, they've done it for a while
but if you're a foreign channel,
so I could put like French titles.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Right?
So that was just one more, it was a guide
and I clicked on it and I'm pretty sure
it was like an Indian
guide fully in like Indian.
And I was like, "What the fuck?
Why is the title in English?"
It's like how to fix your
Android five problem.
I was like sick, "That's
exactly what I want."
I click on it and he
starts talking Indian,
and I'm like, "What the fuck?"
And like, there was no
subtitles or anything.
- [Joey] Right.
- So I was like, "Who,
Why, why would you do this?
- Because it like auto
translates the titles, right?
- But you have to approve that I think.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- No, but like, I've done that before
with like, 'cause I watch
like a lot of Japanese videos
as well with like Japanese titles
and for some reason every now and then
there's a video where if I search for it,
it's displayed in Japanese.
But the moment I click on it,
the title turns to English.
- Is it the dude who makes
the knives out of shit?
- That one too, but also there's
like a bunch of just like,
like a lot of like
Vtube clips, for example
are written in Japanese,
in the search bar.
But then the moment I click
it, it turns to English.
- Yeah, I've noticed that as well.
And I feel like-
- Why?
- Yeah, I don't know.
Which is why I feel
like YouTube getting rid
of close captions is like
my biggest fucking mistake.
I don't know why they're doing it.
- There were like 0.5% who use them.
I was like, "That's still
0.5% of how many million,
who won't?
(Joey laughing)
that's insane guys.
- The entire YouTube
community's crying right now.
- Right?
- How about we make it, hm, worse?
- Are you saying we have to hard Saab-
- Our videos?
Hard saabs, eww.
- You know, that feature that allows me
to conveniently change subtitles
depending on which language-
- Yeah.
- Oh wow, that would be stupid, man.
Let's get rid of that.
(chuckling)
- Uh, fuck you?
- I can use serve dumb something.
Jesus fucking Christ, I can't believe it.
- Stop changing YouTube.
- Stop changing for the worst.
- Stop changing.
- They're like, "How about we
do the 50th logo redesigned
to more minimalism.
The color red is now our logo,
but let's take out all the good features."
and it's like, "Oh, okay. I guess, yeah."
Jesus, they take so many ELLs.
Remember they did the,
like, what was that?
What was the funniest one?
The YouTube heroes do remember that one?
- Oh, my, what was that again?
- Like they were gonna
like make mods basically
out of like YouTube users
where they could like-
- Oh I remember that.
- I remember that.
- There was a fucking
mess, it was so funny.
(all chuckling)
- Thank God.
- All right, here's the
question to you guys then?
Because I don't know if
I'm like, just getting old
or is if this is just like, boom at all.
But do you feel like,
the golden age of the internet has passed?
Or has there even been a
golden age of the internet?
- I don't know.
- I think the wild wild West has gone.
- Yeah, definitely. Like-
- Right.
- If I were to say, I don't know,
because like golden of something
is such a fucking subjectifying-
- What do you defines as golden age?
- Its so subjective-
- In the best period.
- But like this period based on what?
Like-
- I mean, it's subjective.
- Yeah, right, based on like
your personal experience with it,
or like best like objectively,
or like based on something or other.
Like, because I can argue that like, okay
like my personal golden
age of the internet
would be now because it's-
- Its just easy to use now.
- It's just easy to use.
Like, you know, you
can get any information
with anything and everything
is so conveniently laid out.
But best experience in terms
of like, my overall enjoyment
of it would be like the mid 2000's,
because that was like
the golden age of like
new grounds and like flash games.
And like, that shit was so fucking fun
and none of that exists anymore.
- I mean, now when I
download something I'm like
99% sure it's not a virus.
Whereas back then it
was the opposite ratio
Where I was like, "This is virus,
but I really want that cool mouse though.
That mouse popped up really
cool with the sprinkles.
I really want that."
- "I wanna turn my cursor
into like a little cat."
- "I think I want nine
toolbars," you know?
I remember the horror where
my mom showed me her laptop
and I thought I fuck one of her pieces.
But she had like four
internet Explorer tab.
Like fucking toolbars,
and I'm like, "Oh God."
(Garnt chuckling)
- Yeah, you know, like at
the time, like I hated it.
But you know, the, the reminiscent
like times of like going onto my mom's PC
having to swim through all
the pop-ups just to get
to where I needed to go to, was like,
I hated it at the time.
But now I look back and it's like,
"Oh yes, internet do
used to be like that."
- Because I feel like
everything now is, you know,
it's everything is more
formulaic, more clean.
- Yeah.
- I'd say everything
has been like optimized.
As we were saying, it's like the internet
has definitely been optimized,
and you know, that's why
I bring up the argument
of like was it better when it was like,
had this charms, when you feel like
you are discovering something new
and it felt fresh, you know?
Or now that everything's formulaic,
everything's laid out, everything's clean.
That it's just less fun.
- I mean, the whole, like...
As I was saying earlier,
like the whole like mystery
of like discovering a new anime, right?
Like back then in like the mid 2000's
it was like fucking
great because it was like
going into a goldmine that
hadn't been discovered yet.
- And like, you know,
it was the whole thing
but at the same time it was
a double-edged sword, right?
It was like, do I dare click on this anime
to try and discover it with
the risk of possibly getting
I don't know, like seven Trojan horses
coming into my house, you know?
It's like, do I take the risk?
It's like, oh, wild,
wild West, here we go.
But nowadays it's like,
if I click on the link
like I'm fairly certain,
I'm gonna get something
and it's probably going to be something
I've already heard off, right?
The entire mystery of it is gone.
Like, Oh my God, the fucking...
The amount of time I spent on
like newgrounds, for example
just going through just the
most shittiest of cartoons
and flash games to find that one game
or cartoon where it's just like,
"I'll never fuck-"
- Do you remember the
first time you discovered
like the fucking stick
figure fights on newgrounds?
And it was just like the best ever.
You're like, I don't
need top 10 anime fights,
I have like jaljao, whatever
the fuck he's called.
(both chuckling)
- Dude, the moment I discovered
"The Ultimate Showdown
of Ultimate Destiny."
(screams)
- Oh my God!
- Like that shit, when
I found that I was like,
"This is peak internet,
nothing will top this
no movie or experience will ever top this?
- That was the song, right?
- Yeah.
♪ This is the ultimate
showdown of ultimate destiny ♪
- This thing I've had
the Harry Potter puppets-
- Yeah, same guy.
When I first discovered
that I was like, dude,
this is my entertainment
for the next 20 years.
Like, I will never get bored of this.
(Garnt chuckling)
- I don't know if it's because
I'm just tired as fuck,
in like a shitty mood in general.
(all laughing)
It's just, it's sad, the internet now.
I don't know, I just feel like
I'm fucking fatly injected
like a stream of content constantly,
especially on like Facebook and Twitter.
It's just like, I just
scroll, and I'm like (sighing)
- Ever thought about detoxing?
It feels like you need a detox,
because when you start multitasking
with your entertainment
that's when I'm just like,
"Okay, maybe this is too much.
I'm not even enjoying this anymore."
When I'm having a league
game, and a YouTube video,
and music on the same
time, you're just like
you're not enjoying any
of these singular things.
- I don't know if it's out there,
I don't know if it's just because
the way that the like Facebook
and Instagram and Reddit,
they're all set up where it's just
like permanently feeding you something.
- Yeah.
- Where like, even if I detox
from at the moment I get
right back into it, like
it's just gonna be the same shit again
where I feel like, I don't know.
I feel like I'm constantly
being like manipulated now.
- It's like legitimate needs,
like serial experiments systems.
- No, it is, I mean like-
- These systems know exactly
what we wanna fucking say,
and they know what's gonna
make us luck and it works.
And I feel like back then it was exciting,
and it was really like
rough around the edges,
and I didn't mind talking to strangers.
(both chuckling)
Remember that room when you didn't mind
talking to a stranger and be like, "Hey-"
- I missed the times of like
booting up MSN messenger
and seeing like 70 like
friend requests from people
I had no idea, I'm like, "I'm
sure these are nice people."
- I too made some friends who like,
I still too keep in touch
with one or two of them
who are like complete random people, I-
- Yeah.
- I like made really good friends with.
I met them in person as well,
like that was really genuine.
And it also felt because it
was rough around the edges
and it was normally a
very small team making
these huge websites, right?
Like, it didn't feel
like anyone was trying
to take advantage of anyone,
it was just a community.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Now, it feels like,
yes, there is a community
but I'm also just a fucking like,
just one of those fucking
chickens in the pen
just like, "Oh, please give
me a drop of water, please.
So I can get real fat for you,
and you can sell my advertising money."
You know what I mean? I just feel like-
- The social, close cooperate scums.
- I would feel like a chicken in there.
- I honestly feel that
attention fatigue nowadays
is a real thing.
- Oh, yeah.
- where like you talk about you.
I just wanna get up a game
of league and just do it,
the beeping and it boops, right?
(all chuckling)
And that's because you just
want something that's familiar,
it doesn't take a lot of
effort, you know how it works.
'Cause that's like, just
because the internet nowadays
has become so good at
getting your attention.
It's just like, I got I
some serotonin for you.
I got some serotonin for
you right here, right here.
Just take a sling-
- Yeah, like it'll be
like, Twitter will be like,
"Hey a tweet you missed."
And it'll pop up as a notification,
I'm like, Don't do that,
stop, stop that, stop.
- 'Cause remember when
going onto the internet
was like a fucking event?
I was like, "All right,
Mom's out of the house
which means she's not using the phone.
Which means the dial up is gonna be just
a little bit faster, let's go.
- I had a real like fucking
moment the other day.
Audio listeners wouldn't
be able to see that.
I like fell back a little bit.
- Yeah.
- I remember that like, you know,
let's say you posted
something that blew up, right?
Now, you'll know immediately.
Do you have to log out of
a website, log back in,
check that inbox, You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- Like weird, I just
remembered that we did that.
- I mean, I just like
recently upgraded my computer
as we established last episode.
And like I had to log back into everything
and it really like said
something when I was like-
- I haven't logged out yet.
- Shit, what's my password again?
(Garnt chuckling)
Because everything just
stays logged in, right?
So I'm like, I swear, like out
of the 10 something websites
that I had to log into like eight of them,
I was like forgot password.
(Both chuckling)
I don't know.
- Yeah, I don't know
which YouTuber it was,
they messaged me and I
didn't reply for a whole day.
'Cause I just stopped
replying to like messages
on like a Saturday or a Sunday,
whichever day I'm feeling.
I don't mean just trying
to take one day off.
I ignore like, I guess not important.
Like if it's business-related
or like even like
YouTuber friend's, I'll
just ignore it for a day.
'Cause I'm like, I just
want to chill, play games,
not have to worry about
work or anything like that.
- Yeah.
- Just kinda, yeah, that's what...
I thought Mayline was
laughing but she was coughing.
(all laughing)
- Pathetic,
everyday is business.
- Stop fucking dying Mayline.
Yeah, I don't know like, and
I remember they were like,
"Oh, that's weird."
I'm like, "Is it weird
that I don't wanna be like
communicated to every fucking day?
Like, I don't know.
- I mean it gets tiring.
- Yeah. I don't know, I feel weird.
I'm I fucking boomer?
I'm a boomer now?
Shit, maybe I'm a boomer dude.
- Don't say boomer,
when you're the youngest
person in this room.
- I feel like a boomer when
I'm looking at my fucking phone
is like, "Hey, here's a
post you missed on Reddit."
And I'm like, "I don't care."
I've never cared about any of those posts
that's recommended, ever.
Like stop recommending me, I can probably-
- I genuinely wonder, if some
people get those notifications
like, "Oh, I'm glad they
fucking notified me."
(both chuckling)
- It must work because they keep doing it.
Like it must have a rate of
success that's worth doing it.
And it's fucking annoying.
- I guess so, yeah.
- I can probably turn
off somewhere, I should-
- I turn it off.
- I just don't know, I probably-
- 'Cause it's too much effort to find out
how to turn it off, right?
- It's like I could unsubscribe from about
50% of emails I get, but
it's like, Oh, for fuck sa...
I just delete it.
Like, it's like a natural joke reaction
but I should probably just unsubscribe it,
get rid of it, but I don't-
- It sounds like you do
actually just need a detox from-
- How do I do it?
What if Mr. Beast is giving
out a million dollars
every day on Twitter, when I'm not there?
(Joey chuckling)
- I need to ratio him,
to get that $10,000-
- What if its just Connor
will be the one day
where something big happens?
- I don't know you just
don't care for a while.
You just try not looking at your phone
for an entire fucking day.
- I need an incentive,
I can't just do that.
That's hard.
- Just get good.
- If you give me a challenge, I'll be-
- I mean like, this is
like properly talking
to like fucking addicts talk, right?
(Joey laughing)
'Cause like, do you feel
like you have a problem
because if you don't think
you have a problem, then-
- Everyone I know has a problem, Garnt.
I don't know anyone who
is in the same situation
where they're like, I
love my social media feed.
I love logging into Instagram
daily and checking the story-
- No, but-
- I can't wait to check my stories.
Have you ever heard someone say that?
- But you've got to understand
that we are in a very unique
position where this is our job,
so we never have a break from it ever.
- It's the equivalent to
an office lady being like,
"Oh, I can't wait to
check my emails today."
- I just think everyone's
in the same position.
I just think people just don't
wanna fucking check that.
- Everyone everyone's in the same position
but there's different severalties of it.
You know what I mean?
Like, we have...
Okay, the difference between
us and like most other people
is that we have a vested
interest to keep up
with everything because it's our job.
Like if someone misses
a fucking YouTube video
or fucking like YouTube drama,
it doesn't matter for them.
For us it's just like,
it's the equivalent for us
of you know, being that stockbroker.
Reading the stocks every
day, you know what I mean?
- Shit, it went down my point 1%.
(both laughing)
- Yeah, that's exactly what I'm talking.
That's like the equivalent of like
the situation for us, right?
- Yeah.
- And you've got to realize that,
yeah, it's hacking your brain,
you are becoming dependent on it
because it's also part of your job.
You have a vested interest
to keep up with everything.
But it is like-
- It doesn't matter how
much you like your job,
at the end of the day,
it's still your job.
So eventually whether you like it or not
there's gonna be some
parts of a way, just like,
"Ugh" you know, like think back to when
you first started YouTube,
you first started up your Twitter account
and you were like fucking excited to check
if you got a notification.
- I mean yeah, maybe I guess.
- Yeah.
(Garnt laughing)
Like every YouTuber is like that.
Every YouTube who starts off
and like starts to get some
amount of like numbers,
and has a Twitter is always
excited to go onto the Twitter
to see if they got like
a reply to something
or how many people like their thing.
But we've been doing it for so long now
where it's just like, you know
the same over and over again.
- Okay, think of it this way.
Do you know any other
YouTuber, actual YouTuber
who hits the bell notification?
(Joey chuckling)
You know what I'm saying?
- On a YouTube channel?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I do.
- Wait, you do?
- Yeah.
- Okay, which ones?
- I don't want to miss
like an Internet Historian video, right?
Like I wanna know-
- It's pretty hard to miss,
he uploads like once every three months.
- Yeah, but I want a notification
on my phone when he does
so I can, like-
- I wanna be the first hundred viewers.
- Have you also noticed
that YouTube recommendations
have been kind of shit recently?
- No, I think they've been the opposite.
- Really, they've been better?
- Yeah.
- I think mine have been
garbage recently, I don't know.
- Maybe because you're
watching garbage content.
(Garnt chuckling)
Yeah, there, I said it.
- Maybe it's because-
- No more Anime Man videos to me then,
I'm done watching The Anime.
- No, I feel like just because
you've watched so much YouTube.
- Actually that could be it.
- You know that you just run out.
- You run out of all the good one.
- You just run out of content, right?
- That's true.
- I mean, it's true
like any medium, right?
- Fuck, maybe you are right, Garnt, fuck.
(Garnt laughing)
- I mean, my recommenders has been great
because I've just been
watching Vtube clips.
So all of my recommenders,
it's just Vtube clips I haven't seen.
- Just watch streams at that point, right?
- No, I mean, I do.
- Okay.
- Yeah, but sometimes I
don't wanna go through
a three hour stream to watch
five minutes of it, right?
- True.
- I mean in my mind and I feel like
the best YouTube recommendations is like,
you know the one video it gets recommended
and it's just like a sub minute video
that has like 5 million views.
They're always ended up being amazing.
Like my favorite YouTube genres now
is that a title that it
says exactly what is there,
a video that does exactly
what it says on the title.
Like I remember, like I
saw a video the other day
that was like, ducks
annihilate a bowl of peas.
I'm just like, "All right,
this can't be right."
And it's just a fucking two
ducks, just annihilating
this bawl of peas.
And I'm just like, this is
peak YouTube content right now.
- That's like Twitter content, right?
It's like Twitter videos
put on to YouTube.
- But in terms of like
YouTube recommendations,
I mean there's only a certain
set of content creators
that like I would say,
make content that you
are very invested in.
And you're like getting excited over
when they upload and-
- You always have that like, boom, right?
Of like a certain type of
content, like inside of you.
- And we can talk about the
YouTube as we like on next week.
It's just gonna be the YouTubers episode.
- [Garnt] Yes.
- We're gonna talk about
our favorite YouTubers.
- It's gonna be the
giant shout out episode.
(both chuckling)
- But yeah, I mean, like, I
think YouTube recommendations
comes in like waves, right?
'Cause you like...
All it takes is like one
video and you are recommended.
And then you like recommended...
Your recommendations are
like good for like a good
like few days.
'Cause you're like, "Oh, this
is a new kind of rabbit hole
I've found myself in.
But when you're in that like low moments
when you end up watching so much YouTube,
then you just end up watching-
- You've exhausted the recommended.
- You know, what sucks
about living in Japan
is that everyone uploads
while we're sleeping.
So when I wake up I
already know all the videos
that are gonna be uploaded during my day.
But from people I'm subscribed to.
So I already know like the
best videos when I wake up,
so I can watch all the best videos
in like the first hour,
hour and a half, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- And then I have nothing else.
While I was living in
the UK they were like
coming up gradually during my evening.
So it was always like,
"Oh, this videos, okay,
go back and-"
- I mean, I've had that
problem my entire life.
- Yeah, I know, I mean I know your tim...
Oh, well Australia.
- Yeah, exactly.
We're only one hour difference, so.
- It's so weird for me, 'cause it's like,
Oh wait, okay.
So all the videos are out in the morning
and I've watched all in the morning.
- That's what I like about it.
It's that like you wake up in the morning
and all the content is there for that day.
- But it sucks, when I'm
in the middle of the day
and I wanna watch something,
and there's nothing,
no one's uploading anything, so.
- Right, but then that's why-
- I've never cared about that.
'Cause I've always just-
- I cared about that Garnt, clearly.
'Cause I'm talking about it.
- Shit, that means YouTube
upload schedules actually matter?
- Joey forgot to plug in his PC.
- Shit, that means YouTube
upload schedules actually matter
'cause I thought everyone
was like me who just like
watches videos indiscriminately-
- Just upload whenever.
- Yeah, and just like, Oh,
I'll just watch this video
when I feel like it, I don't
care when it's uploaded.
- I care when it's uploaded.
- Fuck, again, I don't so
much care when it's uploaded
because for me, like my entire
like idea of YouTube content
for that day has always been
like wake up in the morning,
like go down my sub-list be like,
"All right, I'm probably
gonna watch this video,
this video, this video.
- Yeah.
- And then I usually just like, watch it
as I'm like having breakfast
or getting ready for the day.
And then once I've exhausted that selfie
then I'm like, alright,
now I can go on with my day
and actually do productive shit.
It's like out of the way now.
- I just can't do anything
until I've watched
all the good videos today.
- I need my fix of selfie.
- Honestly, I don't think there's
that much good content out there where
I'm just like, I need good con...
Like I don't, there's not enough content
out there that's good
in my mind that can keep me entertained
every day, you know what I mean?
There's like certain
YouTubers where I'm like,
"It's a bang of video and I
know I'm gonna enjoy this."
But most of the YouTube
content you watch is just
fills the time.
- [Connor] True.
- And that's just it, and it's just like
can this fill the time
without me getting bored?
- Is it not weird that like
I don't know if this is just me,
but like has it gotten
to the point now where
like the sub feed has
just basically turned
into like a timeline just to
see what everyone's doing?
You know? It's kind of
like a YouTube timeline.
I'm like, all right, let's see
what people are doing today.
- [Connor] True.
- And it's like, you don't
watch 80% of the videos
that are on your selfie,
but you just do something
because you're wondering like,
"All right, what are they up to now?"
It's weird how that's become-
- I feel bad when don't
watch a YouTube video.
- Oh my God.
(chuckling)
- Oh, my God.
- We're all very tired today.
- We're all very tired.
- This is probably been the most tired
that we've all been for
Trash Taste episode.
Like I slept horribly,
Garnt went to bed at 6:00 AM
and Joey's tied too.
- I'm always tired.
- But you were saying you feel bad when?
- I feel bad when I don't
keep up with YouTube
especially if I know that I'm like,
"Oh man, I just I didn't
watch that new video of you,
I'm sorry, man.
Fuck, I'm a bad friend."
- Have you always done that though?
With like, YouTuber friends?
- I try to keep up with
what my friends make, yeah.
I try to keep up just
so I can like be like,
"Oh nah man, nice, you killed it."
Like if they did
something really ambitious
I'd have to let them know, be like,
"Hey man, you fucking
killed it bro, nice."
- I don't know if that's a rare thing.
'Cause my general understanding is like,
again it's like people
just sub to you to like,
you know, show support of course.
But also to be like, just
to see what's up with-
- It might be different for every viewer,
like this one, I'm sure
not everyone watches
every episode of Trash Taste, right?
- [Joey] Right.
- Or cares about when it
comes out, like I'll give-
- Yeah.
- Even though you should.
You should be watching
every Trash Taste episode.
- Yeah.
- Anyway, this has been
a very weird two hour.
I hope you've enjoyed the
two hour therapy session
between the boys.
- Yeah, this has been like the least,
like I feel like exciting episode.
We're all just tired of shit, we are like,
"What are we fucking doing now?"
- It's just basically
just addicts anonymous.
- It's like-
- I'm addicted to this.
- Hello, Internet, I'm
addicted to the internet
and I need to take a
break and conscious' like,
"I don't have an issue,
I don't know where you...
Oh, maybe I do have an issue, oh okay."
- It's like the shittiest
addicts anonymous,
it's like, "I don't have an issue,
therefore you don't
have an issue, fuck you.
- My league issue, my YouTube issue.
What's the next, dude?
- It's like you want me
to fix your league issue?
Just quit, just stop.
- This heroin is still good.
(all chuckling)
- To bring some positivity
back into the podcast though.
- Yeah, 'cause we need that.
- What?
- Heroin.
- [Mayline] Like the drug?
- Yeah.
- Well, heroin is a drug Mayline, yeah.
That was the joke.
The joke is that heroin is
better than all those things.
- Confirmed, Mayline doesn't
count heroin as a drug.
- [Mayline] Like heroin,
like, you know, character.
- No, not a he...
No.
- No.
- Mayline's equally as tired as us.
- Going down a pint of-
(all chuckling)
- A pint of cocaine.
- Yes to bring some positivity
back into the podcast.
We got spare...
We were send something
super special this week.
- Did we?
- I guess we did.
- Bring it out onto the table.
- On the sub Reddit and the
Twitters, this post blew up
that somebody made a nice
little a quilt for us.
Actually, I think it's
actually a quite large.
Yeah, it's a large.
There was also a letter
included from Shelby,
I believe, right?
- Shelby from Cali, yes.
- I did read it, Shelby.
- Yeah, we did read it.
We're not gonna read
it out on the podcast,
but it was-
- Tear that boy open, boy.
- We read it though, all right.
- So I think there's different
gifts for different people.
Oh, I mean, I assume this is the-
- Yeah, this is the main.
- Well, while you guys opening that,
I'll just go ahead and explain.
We don't have a PO box
and we probably won't.
- Yeah.
- I've had a PO box before
and although it is great
receiving stuff, it's
also equally frustrating
figuring out what the
to do with all the stuff
that you get sent.
And I have so much food go stale on me,
so much fruit go bad.
- Yeah.
- I feel like opening
PO box is kind of like,
you know, like opening
your first discord, right?
It's sounds great in theory.
But then when you get to
a point where you get sent
too much stuff that it's manageable.
That's when it becomes
a second job basically.
- We are like super grateful that people
who wanna send me stuff-
- But that doesn't mean
we're not grateful.
We know you guys wanna send us stuff
and everything like that.
Just at this point, we just
want less things to manage,
you know what I mean?
- Yes, its the worse thing to worry about.
- But like when we see
something cool like this
like get posted on a radio or something
we just wanna see-
- [Connor] Holy fuck.
- Oh shit.
- Jesus.
- [Connor] Holy shit that's huge.
That's the wrong way around.
- The wrong way round.
- Holy fuck, that's confidential.
Audio users can take that
out of context if you like.
Wow, that is...
Audio users what you're
looking at right now
is just a giant Trash Taste quilt.
Oh my God, that's actually amazing.
What the fuck?
Shelby? What the fuck?
But thank you Shelby so much.
- [Joey] Thank you Shelby.
- [Garnt] Thank you Shelby.
- Oh my God.
- Thank you so much.
- Holy shit shout out
to Shelby what an MVP?
- There's like two other
gifts here as well.
- Key rings, I believe
they were Shelby's message.
- Should we open them as well?
- Yes, so the key rings are for Mayline,
you and I, there is a key ring for Mayline
which is the pink one,
a silver one for me,
Green one for Garnt-
- And see here, it say
he says J-G-C and M.
- Oh, okay.
(all chuckling)
- So, there is your C.
- Fantastic.
- Hell, yeah.
You're too nice, Shelby, thank you-
- Thank you so much for-
- Thank you very much
Watching this episode of
Trash Tastes by the way.
We're winding down now.
- Oh, it's an a manga's thing.
- Is it really?
- It's got my little okapas.
- Shit, she's got both
of the ducky macros,
I only Thailand.
- Having glasses.
- Having glasses, oh yeah.
- I have the Rose, that's so cool.
What the fuck?
- Oh my God, this is amazing-
- Can I open yours Mayline?
- [Mayline] Oh, yeah.
- Thank you so much, Shelby.
- That's so fucking
cool, it's got my rose.
- Goddam, some people are too nice, man.
- Yeah, so this is obviously...
This is honestly, one of the
coolest gifts I received.
- Oh, Mayline, this is
pink with like cat ears.
- Mayline loves cats by the way.
- Here, Mayline.
- So yes, if you have enjoyed
this episode of Trast Taste
please let us know your thoughts
and what kind of stuff you
wanna see us do in Trash Tastes.
We wanna evolve it more and
keep doing interesting stuff.
- [Garnt] Yes, what's that?
- I'm opening it to find out.
- All right?
- Hope, hope, hope
you've enjoyed sitting in
on this two hour therapy session.
Maybe even you discovered
something about yourself as well,
hearing us talk about our
addiction on the internet.
- Oh, face masks.
- Oh, okay.
- The cat is probably mine-
- Cat face mask.
- Or Mayline.
- No, I guess Mayline.
Oh, these are jojo masks.
- Oh nice.
- [Garnt] That's awesome, yes.
- Killer queen, oh, Dio
you're approaching me.
(Garnt chuckling)
And Brono Bucciarati, okay, wow.
- That's sick.
- Holy shit.
- Thank you so much Shelby.
- Thank you Shelby, you are MVP.
- But also we want to thank our patrons
on screen right now.
- Yeah, you guys help us support the show
and make it even better.
I love all these people and I'm sure
all the boys do as well.
But if you'd like to support
us as well on the patreon
then make sure to go to
patreon.com/trashtaste.
Also again, follow us on
the Twitter and sub Reddit.
And also don't ask us if we have a PO box.
- Yes, we don't.
(Garnt chuckling)
- 'Cause I know, there's
going to be comments.
The moment people see the quilt
they're gonna be like,
I wanna send something.
- And we really appreciate that.
- We appreciate it.
- We appreciate the sentiment.
We'll take the sentiment.
Yes, thank you very much.
- I've enjoyed the sappy session, I guess.
Well, if you've been trashed taste,
thank you to everyone again.
I very....
So grateful, people are willing to come,
and listen to us talk
and (Connor screaming)
- We'll be happier next
week, I swear to God.
- Yeah, this is why I'm
just fucking depressed.
I'm joking, I'm not-
- We forgot to down a pint of cocaine.
- I'm so tired.
Thank you so much.
- [All] Bye.
(bright music)